bon allez on va faire une interview
maintenant on va baisser la lumière a
d'ailleurs le match de retard
voila voila c'est mal joué mais ça il ya
le sampler aussi tiens je vais vous
mettre au pas le mouv réunis à la
croisière s'amuse agréable
0-0 alors je suis à mon sport
mon prof de gym mais l'enchaînement
sport il mais ça bon alors lit où vous
allez diviser déclaré c'est bizarre j'ai
toujours été une femme seule j'étais
accompagné finalement très peu de temps
et j'ai eu mes enfants avec des hommes
différents
ma célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez et étudier pas été mieux si vous
étiez resté wanda est ce que vous auriez
moins de problèmes avec les hommes oui
pourquoi parce que c'est très difficile
de se retrouver à un moment donné comme
étant monsieur lio et moi je les entends
du ca des gens qui venaient qui
présentait mais mes hommes comme
monsieur lio est en fait moi je trouvais
c'était ridicule de la part des autres
mais eux petit à petit trouvé ridicule
de ma part des trios mais quand est
dommage parce que je l'étais avant je ne
pouvais pas arrêter tout d'un coup
c'était maintenant c'est comme une
seconde nature lio et ça a posé des
problèmes mais ça pose des problèmes
généraux de l'aisne de gagner puisque
son âme
bon alors c'est vrai alors donc voila
moi j'ai fait le compte quand même là
lieux jugés dire d'abord c'est marrant
on trouve normal par contre de dyala
d'un machin madame troni violence en
fourrage france est suffisamment
chamailler sur des plateaux pour que je
puisse vous faire un compliment sincère
je vous trouve très belle en ce moment
là là présentement j'ai amincie très
joli vous êtes j'ai une belle robe vous
et des belles nat et j'adore les brunes
et vous avez du rouge à lèvres un peu
rouge ça ça me fait ça vire béatrice je
te le dise tu pouvais mettre le même
genre de rouge à lèvres que you ça me
ferait plaisir mais bon allez maintenant
à faire vraiment
à l'idée du sud mais c'est normal une
portugaise
ça le fait un renault allait tenter un
show là rien n'est parfait
le réseau il est chaud avant titille
aussi dit national
bon alors j'ai compté les sommes
avancées pas encore gloria lasso mais
quand même c'est sur la route ça c'est à
dire il ya eu d'abord votre premier
duval il faut bien prendre le parolier
on adore tous ben voilà que j'ai 13 ans
et demi oui ensuite il ya eu estévenens
notre ami et ses banques qui vous avez
qui vous avez une vue bien oui ensuite
il eu patrick alexis avec qui il a eu
deux enfants il dort et smeralda dont on
est déjà un deux trois oui non attendez
un nom maintenant 1 2 3 4
zad le dernier en date celui avec qui
vous avez des jumelles voient la photo
elle aimerait beaucoup mais non avant je
suis vieux j'aime les enfants à chaque
fois à l'âge de 5 ans format non c'est
d'ailleurs lui c'est vrai bios et je le
sais moi je vous ai vu à l'été nubia sur
les plateaux il ya aux bains douches
alors vous avez déclaré mon ami hugo
pratt m'avait pourtant conseillé de ne
pas tuer le désirent dans ce milieu
avides de chair fraîche
personne ne veut d'une fille avec cinq
gosses aux basques vous pensez que ça
vous handicape aujourd'hui tous ces
enfants moi c'est moi ça m'a handicapé
merci j'ai eu jean françois van
aujourd'hui un micro sera moi ça mon
handicap pas au contraire dans ma vie de
femme
quelque chose de
de génial mais ça ça handicape dans mon
travail mais oui bien sûr sam handicap
dans mon travail parce que c'est c'est
pas de trouver des gens en général les
femmes veulent bien travaillé avec moi
mais derrière une femme réalisatrice il
ya toujours un homme producteurs et
l'homme producteur lui n'a pas envie
d'une artiste à problèmes entre
guillemets c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
pourrait éventuellement lui refusé de
lui donner la 200e heures
supplémentaires gratos puisque c'est
maintenant ce qu'on vous demande moi
depuis que j'ai commencé à tourner mes
cachets ont été divisés par 3 voire 4
toujours soi disantes pour des problèmes
de cinéma français qui ne marche pas
mais j'ai toujours vu les producteurs
avec la même bmw et les mêmes costumes
chéraute il donc
donc vous voulez je trouve que c'est
comme un nouvel excès esclavagisme parce
que comme on manque de boulot c'est
difficile pour tout le monde donc on
commence à dire aux techniciens faut
diviser vos prix et puis si c'est pas
vous qui voit là et donc ça c'est
effectivement et donc qu'il ya autre
chose qui chauffe c'est quand tout d'un
coup des producteurs ont le choix entre
lio nôtres une autre brune pas trop
grosse
ils vont prendre peut-être l'autre brune
joli mais qui a fait cinq enfants et moi
je vais être éliminés sur ce critère
immédiatement oui mais c'est la vérité
je n'ai pas vraiment alonso est pas là
dites moi où est donc tout cas pour une
fille qui a eu cinq enfants des vaches
vont bien pour une fille qui
n'empêcherait canfranc j'ai commencé à 5
enfants ça serait normal brunes tété a
eu 50 ans sauvagement bien j'ai presque
40 ans c'est vrai comment vous faites je
fus semaine
ces détectives orléans sans non plus
n'aura malheureusement non michel
et nous enregistrons alors vous vous
disiez donc là vous avez des problèmes
avec votre jules actuelle et pourtant
vous disiez je crois que j'ai trouvé ce
que je cherchais je suis une butineuse
il me faut un vrai appel pour m'arrêter
avec lui il ya eu une vraie osmose
comment ça se fait que ce soit terminé
aussi mal après cette vraie osmose ah
mais ça je ne sais toujours la question
que je continue à me poser qui ne pose
est celle des sacrés problèmes
je ne sais pas cette question comme ça
se termine mais c'est pas un an
vous aviez l'air d'être tellement
d'avoir enfin trouvé mais je suis très
amoureux s'est dit toujours oui mais je
ne veux plus jamais vivre avec lui vous
allez vous revoir quand même nous on n'a
pas le droit
vous êtes un peu disputées - pas là pour
dire ça dont il a quand même pris deux
mois ferme un oui très d'accord vous ne
vous êtes pas porter visite j'ai pas
porté plainte par vengeance j'ai quand
même un peu porter plainte s'ils ont
atteint près de moi faire parce que
quand on porte plainte c'est qu'on n'a
pas d'autre solution quand on essaye de
régler des problèmes comme on peut avec
ses moyens mais qu'à un moment donné on
va d'échec en échec et de violent sans
violence eh bien on s'en faire à la
justice c'est pas que je trouve ça
formidable mais c'est que je n'avais pas
d'autre solution
la justice représente le père c 'est
c'est une autorité à laquelle on s'en
remet quand on reconnaît notre échec
notre échec à nous de résoudre le
problème voilà mieux vous avez dit que
vous jugiez la sanction un peu sévère là
les six mois fait les six mois de prison
n'ont jamais dit ça je ne je ne suis pas
a priori pour la prison parce que je
trouve que ce n'est pas là qu'on résout
les problèmes mais mais les deux mois
ferme n'était qu'une partie de la
sentence
et moi j'avais besoin de protection et
gelé obtenus et la justice a fait des
grands pas pour les femmes battues il
fallait qu'elle les fasse parce qu'on
est vraiment seul dans ces cas là et
surtout vous êtes toujours coupable mois
la plupart des hommes qui m'ont parlé
depuis n'ont pas du tout le sentiment de
s'adresser à une victime mais c'est
comme les femmes victimes d'un violent
c'est que je les bien cherché comme en
plus on le monde sait que c'est un sale
caractère on se dit que vraiment jésus
torturé ce programme c'est quand même
moi qui avait le nez cassé et le loup
une entorse cervicale et quatre
vertèbres déplacées qu'on a dû remettre
le les folies bergères et que ça et
c'est arrivé que je m'en remets toujours
femmes en tout cas sûr ça ne se voit pas
est certaine ça se voit pas mais ça
c'est la magie du spectacle à new york
oui alors vous vous flippez un peu sur
votre âge que quand on vous voir la du
mal à comprendre franchement ou dit liu
c'est pas moi je la met en scène tous
les jours elles existent palio j'ai fait
un seul coup a dit aux gésiers mais ça
je le disais il ya il ya dix ans déjà de
ça parce que c'est vrai lyon était la
représentation de l'adolescence elle
avait entre 12 et 14 ans quand je les
choisis c'était mon âge à l'époque dans
une bd de de jean claude forest et elle
était le symbole de l'adolescente
oui et c'est vrai que je ne suis plus le
symbole de l'adolescente avec vingt
enfants suspectés suisse a voulu 150 ans
et au ghana oui est-ce que vous je ne
critique pas le ghana je tiens à le dire
je veux pas d'histoires je ne critique
pas gala est-ce que vous avez vous dit
j'ai du mal à me voir vieillir j'ai la
mécanique s'affaiblit ce n'est jamais
très agréable
oui c'est vrai et c'est jamais très
agréable de devoir les heureux les
regards des hommes toujours attiré par
la jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante mais vous êtes une femme dans
la plénitude la wii non il faut pas
flipper lalliot n'ont peut-être cesser
c'est comme ça c'est sans doute une
étape obligée du succès très jeune avec
un personnage de lolita effectivement
banana split et tout ça mais quand on
vous voit là écoutez série mais je crois
une chose je crois que on se voit
énormément
dans le regard que l'homme que vous
aimez portent sur vous et je crois que
quand le regard qu'on reçoit est quelque
chose qui vous a faibli qui vous remet
tellement en question et sur des choses
qui sans doute sont ridicules moi je
trouve que c'est une perte d'énergie
totale mais la vérité est que ça moi ça
me marque il ya des choses qui m'ont
marqué c'est vrai que je me regarde plus
dans la glace avec la même le même la
même désinvolture disons parce que moi
je ne me suis jamais regarder dans la
glace avec attention j'étais désinvolte
et je la perds au port et c'est une peur
qui vient alors je m'en demande y
tourner très vite mais je crois que je
crois que c'est sale tout simplement je
crois qu'on ne vieillit jamais quand les
gens ces gens là devraient voilà moi je
vous dire si je viens plus âgées que
vous problème c'est que dans la tête on
vit pas vraiment mais le corps vie et
puis après les gens les gens n'y croient
pas quand alors dit ça alors visite
quand même j'ai hâte d'être une vieille
dame indigne 8e passer le cap de l'antre
2 jamais avant lui que l'entreprise au
niveau après c'est vrai qu'on a envie à
un moment de se dire ouais elle assigne
à un moment on se dit la vieillesse il
faut que ça serve à ne plus rien avoir à
[ __ ] de rien au moins cet avantage là
c'est ça et de pouvoir faire plein de
conneries et puis personne venu venir
vous dire quelle conne
ça c'est génial ça fait un moment que
j'attends avec une peinture merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview vérité vous est pris
tout à fait j'étais en 1943 c'est un
sale annonce si tu dis il n'a pas
l'habitude de relater les cérémonies
fait juste suite et michaud vous êtes né
en 43 votre mère était aide-soignante à
bitche en moselle dans un hôpital
réquisitionné par les allemands et votre
père avait été dans la ligne maginot qui
est servi à rien il s'est fait peur
prisonniers se retrouvent dans l'hôpital
il rencontre votre mère et vous naissez
puis j'arrive
ensuite vous allez je la fais courte
arts visuels en pension et l'abbé
relâche de 10 11 ans vous subissez les
abysses et l'abus sexuel
je subis pas non je suis témoin dhabi
sexuels sur des enfants parce que nous
étions dans un pensionnat de 2,2
deux frères qui s'appelait saint-nicolas
dini et la mode à ce moment là c'était
de devoir cesser ses frères mettre les
petits garçons entre leur jeu douce et
et leur grand plaisir non trois ans
d'enfer clair vous dites sérieuses mais
oui sérieusement vous êtes raison d'en
faire et où il fallait faire à 11 ans
toutes les frasques pourquoi acquérir
ces gens-là fallait courir vite quoi
entre autres après donc c'est l'époque
de l'algérie et l'avait pris côté un peu
avec le reste
vous mettez des bombes 1 hoyé entre
autres un peu lui dire maintenant elle
n'était pas là n'étaient pas là mais non
encore bombe à l'hôtel de ville ne sais
pas c'est une des affaires que je me
sens je me souviens parce qu'elle
n'avait pas explosé
c'est dû à notre île expérience utile
bombe à retardement elle s'appelle
tiberi alors vous avez parlé à françois
mitterrand de vote votre époque un peu
os comme ça et alors y'a un truc que je
comprends pas c'est que lui il a fait le
parallèle avec ce qu'il a vécu pendant
l'occupation
je vois pas ce qu être comparables sa
part où j'ai peur de comprendre
simplement bon quand on est jeune qu'on
a lui il avait 18 ans quand il est
arrivé à vichy moi j'avais 17 ans quand
il y avait cette guerre on était dans
une période tous les deux de deux
conflits de guerre et lui il avait
besoin de travailler l'été monter à
paris il est redescendu à vichy donc on
lui a accordé un poste dans un ministère
moi j'étais jeune chien fou j'avais
envie de bouger j'avais envie de
m'ennuyer chez moi donc je suis parti
avec ses sept banques
quittez pas toujours très fréquentables
journée donc c'était surtout un petit
parallèle mais weck a rien de c'est un
peu des erreurs de jeunesse lui sur les
la francisque et vous cette elwes et ça
voulait dire par exemple mais la charge
est contrôlé j'ai compris alors vous
faites tellement de conneries
finalement georges est obligée de
choisir entre la prison où vous la remet
à l'armée
et vous avez choisi l'art mais voilà
alors je la fais courte en 60 de vous
retrouver dans les paras envahie en
algérie en 69
vous rentrez un peu de la politique fait
la campagne de pauvres hères toute
personne c'est qu'il pourrait
aujourd'hui ça j'imagine repas pour
peter un boulevard aux enfers
harper en 71 vous rencontrer franceschi
alfortville the big alfortville l'époque
mitterrand montre le ps c'est l'épreuve
de fines et 1
vous prenez votre carte du parti
socialiste détient socialistes n'ont
entendu tout nous en 74 ou participer à
la campagne de mitterrand c'est quand il
a perdu contre giscard d'estaing
regarder ça et après la défaite
buvez un pot avec lui comme ça enfin
quelques jours après vous première fois
vous conduisez dans votre ds ta famille
est très sale et puis madiba en émoi à
saint germain des prés voilà et là tout
aurait pu aller bien pour vous tout
aurait pu être formidable et vous
recommencez les conneries w mais est ce
que je vais dire charlotte je parlais du
fim double vie d'un côté et liam avec
les enfants et de l'autre côté annie
avec julie et ce qui est bien c'est
sympa qui est très sympathique
enfin bon il ya eu un problème j'ai eu
un petit peu le même que mitterrand
d'ailleurs c'est que votre enfant est
mort d'un mort subite du boulot j'ai
vite et mitterrand et avait le même
problème après la grande en 46 mais avec
daniel et la rapprocher un petit peu je
sais pas c'est tout ça ces concours de
circonstances qui vont quand même une
personne pas je vais pour ça qu'il était
tellement attaché mazarine en même temps
quand on sait ça moi je me savais aussi
ça quand on sait qu'il a perdu une
petite fille en très très bas âge
peut-être que c'est pour ça qu'il a
reporté tellement d'amour sur sur mazars
et voilà vous c'est dur pour vous vous
conduisez le cercueil à digne dans la
famille de de votre ami dix ans et là
vous tombez dans l'alcool la dépression
un peu clochard le clochard et bien soir
j'étais entre deux voitures allongé dans
le milieu de la route se franceschi pas
s'est dit tiens il ya un chien qui
encore en train de mourir entre deux
voitures
dd va voir ce qui se passe d'aidé
boussioux et jaguar gardien qui dit non
c'est passé princiens c
pierre tourlier qui est en train de
sombrer alors il me ramasse il met dans
sa voiture il monte chez moi il dit
demain je dois au bureau en état mais
nous a drôlement est déjà là quand même
très franche et ce qui est acté
franceschi si elle est maire
d'alfortville un député maire
d'alfortville et alors là donc ils vous
demandent de protéger le premier
secrétaire du parti donc françois
mitterrand et vous dites dès cet instant
j'ai compris que mon destin était lié à
cet homme racontez votre première
journée quand vous les avez tous années
chez dos d'un bouffon puisque vous
regarde que lui ça la clé visage là
alors de ces basses et le premier jour
le soir donc on le midi la vitesse dans
un restaurant puis le soir on arrive
place maubert à côté de la rue de bièvre
et puis il me dit bon ben je déjeune à
indy l'avant ce qui avait
d'extraordinaire c'est françois
mitterrand c'est que jamais il disait
aux chauffeurs vous restez en voiture
vous m'attendais françois mitterrand il
avait cette allure extraordinaire c'est
qu'il dise on chauffeur aurait quelqu'un
de lui faire manger en cuisine il a dit
et ce soit côté de moi et donc la fin
françois mitterrand était extraordinaire
pour ça et donc je m'assieds à une table
pas très loin de lui et puis je vois qui
m'observent et roger hanin aussi qui
m'observent mais moi j'avais mon couteau
et me fourchette savait plus comment
servir tellement c'était impressionnant
quoi un levier le trac mais tout à fait
ou dit la voiture c'était une sa bulle
son havre de paix et alors ça sert à
quoi il écoute est vraiment thing floyd
dans la voiture willy coûteux pink floyd
ça c'est ce qui m'a le plus étonné
depuis dix ans mitterrand qui coûte
bankrun pile de feuilles supertramp les
bee gees c'est qu'ils chantaient des
chansons jamais cru ça c'est un truc que
mitterrand écoute les bee gees dans sa
qu'elle soit un peu qu ils veulent c est
donc là je parlais de mazari vous
découvrez la double vie
de françois mitterrand donc un reproche
un petit peu parce que lui je pense
qu'ils devaient savoir comment ça se
passe pour moi donc c'est ce qui nous
rapproche un petit peu un bout de trois
semaines où il prend part la bras le
bras en sortant de la route biel et me
dit tiens je crois que nous allons
travailler longtemps ensemble
alors vous dit d'ailleurs qu'il y avait
avec danielle mitterrand à un couple qui
était bâtie sur le respect mutuel c'est
ce que vous dites et puis avec anne
pingeot une véritable passion amoureuse
quoi passion amoureuse pour sa fille il
était subjuguée par elle est alors
totale autour de ça il ya une omerta
considérable enfin vous le saviez vous
vous étiez au courant que j'ai tous les
gens là ils étaient au courant
apparemment ils n'ont jamais dit aux
gens qui lisent les journaux mais je
crois que c'est l'honneur des français
de savoir faire ça c'est à dire que l'on
peut être au courant de certaines choses
on a beaucoup de déboires en jeu pour
planquer nommé chacun ses qualités en ce
moment moi j'évite en espagne et bien je
peux te dire que la presse si tu veux et
d'un trash et d'un et c'est vrai que moi
je suis le voit choqué je me dis je on
n'a pas souvent l'occasion aux joueurs
d'être fiers d'être français sur ce truc
là je trouve que l'on est assez classe
ouais bien alors vous dites que mazarine
et la lave la femme de sa vie en fait il
alors il ya un très beau très beau
moment quand il vous dit dépêchez-vous
pierre on va chercher d'hasagic appelé
comme ça à l'école et là bon vous vous
découvrez un mitterrand complètement
transfiguré en fait tu risques ans à
être subjugué par sa fille quand elle
arrive quand je vais la chercher à
l'école je la prend par la main en plus
moi c'était un petit peu le renouveau de
ma fille que je venais de perdre et donc
je l'amène à la voiture et on voit ce
françois mitterrand qui est heureux
2 à travers la ville on voit qu'il est
heureux de recevoir sa fille de de
démarrer des camps des maris l'embrasser
la câline et on arrive devant chez elle
et la douve la porte et vous à mazarine
partir et là ils le disent une triste
d'un père qui sépare de serment de la
raison d'elle alors qu'il ya toutes les
autres femmes que il vous disait j'aime
être aimé quel mal y at-il à ça et vous
vous dites hui volume 6 tiré par les
cheveux et ses conquêtes quant à l'or il
ya christine à la suédoise donc vous
confirmez à une certaine voie sans
musique qui peut pas être le père de
l'enfant parce que l'époque la maladie
l'interdisait la paternité sur les
loyers elizabeth teissier donc
l'astrologue ok mais qui croyaient le
str au logis de rester si je reste ici a
dit qu'elle voyait mitterrand mais qu'en
fait ils croyaient vachement à
l'astrologie qui voulait faire une
chaîne une chaire pardon de d'astrologie
la sorbonne me dit que c'est du pipeau
tout cela est filmé sentence elle a tapé
dix ans intéressés s'emmerder je vais
c'est chez lui parler de l'astrologie
pendant des mois et en même temps bon
c'est une personne agréable à regarder
voilà j'ai pas mal travaillé des trucs
ils sont rigolos un joaillier de
militante du ps il drague et puis nous
dragon passé la soirée avec l année
qu'elle ait un jour mitterrand
non maintenant une militante du ps et sa
fille qui drague pierre voilà et puis je
me laisse aller et puis quelques jours
plus il va chez elle il s'aperçoit que
c'est un endroit où il avait déposé
mitterrand puis à quelques jours avant
ces français au moins ces mots choc non
écoute
ouais non mais c'est intéressant comme
bouquins et alors il ya une nuit mais il
ya une ive détecte une femme dans un lit
est quelqu'un qui téléphone qu'elle vous
dire de la chambre dira de son
appartement et jetés sans vitesse
m'habillant sur le palier et je sort de
l'immeuble tourner la tête au moment un
taxi arrive et je reconnais le style
ouverts en france qu'ils venaient mais
là aussi j'ai prévenu la chandelle
j'adore il y arriver tp a brillé à la
fin après c'est pas s'étaler là dessus
parce que
quand il vous dit ça y est pierre ça se
termine je suis désolé en fait de faire
du chagrin à ceux qui m'aiment et qui
vont suivre en raison de son grand grand
souci c'était la mort c'est ce qui gêne
est le plus c'était de faire du souci du
du chagrin ce qu'il l'aimait la dernière
fois ils à vis de vous l'avait conduit
en voiture il était il avait des
mauvaises nouvelles de son toubib et
vous lui dites fondé par le docteur tard
au fait de voir d'autres lui une
dernière fois vous allez voir paris vous
saviez pas que la dernière fois bien ton
nom
donc vous avez regretté à près de palu à
voir rester accroché au volant et
pommeau a déclaré jean ont alors vous
dit pour conclure j'avais perdu le père
que je n'avais pas eu françois
mitterrand était le dieu une religion
que je n'avais pas
et je vais vous faire une interview
vérité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien qu'en servi de très intéressant oui
vraiment pas ce qu'on apprend des trucs
alors là d'abord vous parlez du business
du business du tennis féminin et vous
relevé des choses tout à fait enfin une
fois qu'on les a lus dans votre bouquin
évidemment je dis oui c'est vrai mais
bon on n'y avait pas pris conscience par
exemple qu'une fille comme martina
hingis soit photographiée par tous c'est
normal c'est la numéro deux mondiale
donc c'est normal qu'elle soit partout
et vous parler par exemple d'une fille
qui s'appelle anna kournikova qu'ils
aient jamais gagné un tournoi et qu'on
voit partout il ya des gros contrats de
sponsoring c'est à dire qu'en fait
finalement ce que vous dénoncez d'une
certaine façon dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le tennis féminin
bah ça commence à être plus le look que
le jeu oui c'est ça c'est ce que je
dénonce mais bon c'est bien pour un
accord- courage ça me ça me fait plaisir
qu'elle gagne autant parce qu'elle est
sexy elle est jolie c'est vrai mais je
trouve que quand même ce qui est
important c'est qu'on regarde le jeu des
joueuses aussi quand les gens viennent
nous voir jouer on regarde d'abord bon
c'est vrai c'est lé minium tant mieux
mais regardent ils viennent voir jouer
une joueuse quoi alors vous y allez pas
de main morte à
nathan
ça balance ceci alors alors là
kournikova vous dit qu'un jour vous la
surprenait dans les vestiaires avec deux
portables un parent boyfriend
ça vous choque ça non ça me chante pas
ça me fait rigoler ouais penser qu'elle
a tort de elle joue avec ça en tout cas
elle joue beaucoup avec ça elle s'amuse
bien oui vous n'êtes pas jalouse pas du
tout alors toujours dans le business
vous vous annoncez vos gains qu'ils sont
en brut 1 9 million pour 98 par exemple
mais en fait après impôts les dépenses
de fonctionnement il vous reste deux
millions plutôt que vous dit en fait
j'ai pas gagné ça toute ma vie donc il
faut que j'en profite parce que là c'est
enfin je sais pas si c'est votre
dernière saison ou pas on ne sait pas
encore mais en tous les cas ce ça risque
alors à par steffi graf et lindsay
davenport tout le monde y passe un nom
dans votre bouquin williams vous dites
au moment d'entrer dans le court monde
entré sur le court pardon elle vous
regarde comme si vous étiez une naine et
ne croyez pas que c'est un jeu ça c'est
comme à la boxe quand mohamed hajji il
dit à l'autre et interminable je vais
t'écraser n'ont cessé un jeu on se
regarde un petit peu bizarrement dans
les vestiaires avant de rentrer même sur
le court au changement de côté on
n'hésite pas à bien se regarder dans les
yeux et et à se dire maintient la
prochaine j'étais tu vas voir tu m'as
pas pouvoir la voir quoi monica seles
alors êtes-vous dit cet excédent est là
un excédent de bagages pour pondérale
pour aller à monica seles monica seles
elle a beaucoup apporté au tennis parce
que parce qu'elle est arrivée elle
prenait elle était carrément dans le
court elle prenait la balle très tôt moi
personnellement elle a fait remettre en
question mon jeu et
c'est grâce à elle aujourd'hui j'ai un
jeu très offensif rinne a une qui
n'avaient pas de main morte c'est mary
pierce vous dit j'espère qu'elle
s'arrête à la créatine faut pas nous
prendre pour des imbéciles on sait bien
que la créatine ça peut masquer d'autres
produits ouais c'est la vérité ouais
oui c'est la vérité mais enfin c'est
comme toutes les vérités pas tout le
monde les explique tout le temps non
mais c'est bien mauresmo vous lui
reprochez enfin vous reprochez rien du
tout d'ailleurs mais vous dites que
c'est dommage que sa petite amie soit
devenu son entraîneur parce qu'il faut
pas mélanger
j'ai dit chacun sa place elle c'est vrai
que je trouve que si on a un coach sur
le circuit sa lune expliquer si on a
bien joué on a joué je vois mal mon
petit copain à venir me dire oui tu as
joué comme une brêle aujourd'hui
extérieur c'est pas son rôle
il a plutôt pour me consoler plus tôt
quand j'ai perdu et être sympa avec moi
quand j'ai gagné plutôt que vous pensez
qu'elle mélange un peu trop laid
justement en parlant de maurice nous
l'homosexualité dans le tennis féminin
c'est un mythe ou une réalité
bah pas plus qu'ailleurs ouais pas
puisque énorme demande en général oui
pas plus que dans le tennis masculin
quoi je suis pas trop dans mon fils je
sais pas je dis joueuses et là combien
qu'ils soient homosexuels pour voir 2 2
oui moi passent comme partout alors
voilà par comme ici ce soir autour de
cette table
bellemare il emmerde et la wallonie l'aï
les premières du genre
catherine me dit en colère maintenant
vide pendant vous en tous les cas on
vous a suspecté je dirais
d'homosexualité vous dites vous niez
vous dit j'ai pas de mec parce que je me
suis contenté enfin je me suis consacré
à mon jeu et si j'avais eu un mec c'est
l'expression j'ai répondu comme du sucre
donc c'est vrai vous avez en fait j'ai
sacrifié votre vie amoureuse au tennis
et fernand le plateau farida vous placer
alors qu'en ce moment je suis en 1953
j'ai 47
je suis déjà plus le pas sur vous
profitez-en
non mais c'est vous avez vous avez chez
vous mais c'est fort comme vous et
sacrifier votre vie amoureuse si vous
dites je suis pas homosexuel bon c'est
vrai qu'on voit jamais qu'un garçon puis
si on boit jamais qu'un garçon c'est
parce que je me consacre au tennis pour
moi jamais je veux dire j'ai pas eu des
petits copains titrait pendant longtemps
comme ça mais et puis j'ai pas envie de
tout mélanger quoi ouais voilà c'est
tout alors il ya par les défis pour
parler aussi d'un garçon senora alors là
vous y allez pas de main morte non plus
hein je sais pas moi j'ai lu le bouquin
vous dites il représente tout ce que
j'ai toujours combattu dans ma vie le
travail à court terme par à-coups enfin
hold up et hop ça parce que je pense que
yannick aurait fait faire une carrière
way meilleurs s'ils n'avaient pas fait
tout ce qu'il a fait quoi et un peu
comme mauresmo c'est à dire c'est des
gens qui s'éclate en jouant ouais c'est
ça mais moi aussi je m'amuse en jouets
mais vous êtes quand même plus tight
vous non voilà voilà
eux ils s'éclatent en jouant tous marais
quoi alors que vous vous êtes plus
rigoristes d'une certaine façon
bourreuse way et vous dites j'ai lu dans
un journal cette semaine on the magazine
vous est il est inabordable
voilà pour moi oui là ça a été dur on a
pas su c'est peut-être de ma faute aussi
j'ai peut-être su assez bien communiquer
avec lui alors le tennis féminin vous
dites donc c'est plus en plus sexy donc
c'est plus en plus lourd que la beauté
les love story les scandales les
critères athlétiques disparaissent au
profit des critères esthétiques
c'est quoi la comique ma liste cette
madeleine oui la comédienne glisse et
quand vous faites partie des 20
meilleures joueuses du monde
les directeurs de tournois choisissent
les meilleures joueuses qui veulent
avoir dans leur tournoi donc ils font
bah voilà nous on aimerait avoir une
guide d'avesnes fort dans quel plus il
ya de directeur de tendre à qui les
veulent
plus serein en haut de la liste quoi
rien à voir avec le classement atp en
fait c'est ses terres wta pour vous oui
mais c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est un en fait c'est un classement
jean leloup que c'est pas un classement
sur les sur les qualités sportives sur
les ventes de billets quoi estime qu'à
une distance de billets ou kournikova
plus vente de billets que que julie
halard ou comme moi voilà donc à moi je
suis 5e mondiale et sur cette liste je
suis 16e quoi chose quand ils auront vu
ça là vous allez le premier à la salle
armand ce petit bout de magnéto qu'on a
vu que la couverture du livre à mon avis
que vous n'allez pas sur le court comme
ça j'aurais po numéro anne lacaud
mythomane liste alors vous dites vous
dites donc le tennis féminin est de plus
en plus sexy
c'est ce qu'on vient de dire est
toujours aussi sexiste c'est à dire que
les garçons s'agit aussi appris s'enlise
en tout cas son pays deux fois plus que
vous deux fois plus sur le sur le
circuit en général oui mais dans les
grands chelems n'ont quand même pas tout
à fait en gains on se rapproche de plus
en plus du prize money des garçons mais
c'est pas ça encore donc c'est vrai
qu'on demande aujourd'hui on demande des
joueuses on demande à voir égalité de
prix du moins dans les grands c'est
normal parce que le tennis et des femmes
et parfois plus intéressant que les que
les hommes surtout dire qu'ils
payeraient les il payerait les hommes à
la vitesse de la balle en fait oui c'est
ça c'est alors que l on ait fait du pet
dans les grands chelems on nous dit
ouais mais les garçons jouent 5,7 et
vous enjouer que trois mais bon au
niveau de télévision aujourd'hui on est
au dessus quoi donc bon enfin tous les
cas c'est un livre très intéressant que
je recommande à nos amis dont c'est chez
plon les dessous du tennis féminin par
la territoriale
e
mathilde seigner bonsoir bonsoir alors
mathilde jeudi soir vous devez monter
les marches pour la présentation du team
harry un ami qui vous veut du bien de
dominik moll avec sergi lopez c'est un
des quatre films français en compétition
quel effet ça vous a fait mathilde être
la reine d'un soir à cannes bat
s'énoncer c'est extraordinaire d'autant
plus que je dis on a une mais innovation
quoi le film a été vraiment mais jeudi
la fille prétentieuse très très applaudi
non ça a été incroyable je sais pas si
tous les films sont applaudis comme ça
mais en tout cas là pendant un quart
d'heure les gens étaient debout et
c'était très émouvant quoi en fait c'est
moi moi qui disais cannes je m'en fous
machin en fait je suis très contente
c'est vrai que le film comparer on dit
un petit peu que ça va être comme la vie
rêvée des anges pour l'an 2000 c'est
vrai c'est possible intérieur mieux moi
que la vie rêvée des anges bravo mais
alors c'est vrai que vous au départ vous
juillet le jeu de cannes avec un petit
peu de recul un petit peu de distance
en parlant de la grande foire cannoise
et finalement vous avez chaud quand même
où a été séduite quoi ouais nan mais je
râle je râle et puis après effectivement
contente mais là je suis super contente
un peu fatigué mais je suis contente
quand vous étiez enfant en fait vous
n'aviez pas du tout rêver de le faire du
cinéma vliet comédienne de théâtre
vous pensez que vous étiez pas alors
c'est incroyable ça vous pensez que
j'étais pas assez belle pour faire du
cinéma où il ya deux chanteuses
non je pensais pas exactement ça je
pensais que que pour faire du cinéma
fallait très joli mais parfaite quoi
genre mais comme bardot tout décor
parfait pas de rien quoi sublime et en
fait donc voilà donc je pense donc je me
disais que moi je pouvais pas en faire
mais en fait j'en fait bon et en fait
j'en fais bien surtout la vie qui dit en
fait tout le temps et en fait gens
savent à quoi on s'en fout faye a pas
que des belles quoi bien alors on va
parler un petit peu du film ah ouais
d'accord
alors un ami qui vous veut du bien de
dominik moll qui avait fait intimité en
93 way blanc c'est un film de genre
c'est un polar sauf un peul a fait un
film de genre et c'est un film qui
renoue un peu enfin à mes yeux avec les
film de clouzot en tout cas le film pour
moi halak vraiment la qualité des films
de clouzot des diaboliques et de tout ça
un peu plus haut un peu chabrol un peu
élevé chabrol mais et puis beaucoup du
pack aussi et beaucoup romane polanski
et beaucoup tout ça quoi
alors c'est l'histoire d'un type qui
s'incruste dans la vie d'un couple de
deux jeunes français moyen et puis qui
va tuer pour des raisons que je dévoile
pas parce qu'il faut voir le film
soucier des raisons très étrange quand
même oui c'est à dire qui pousse en fait
son copain qu'il retrouve après beaucoup
de temps il le pousse à larguer sa vie
banale à devenir écrivain c'est ça ouais
à devenir écrivain parce qu'il il
écrivait des poèmes quand il était jeune
et il le pousse à ça et en fait ils le
débarrasse failli y tue pour faire le
bien il a l'impression qu'il aime quoi
lui par amour ils l'aiment et il élimine
beaucoup de gens autour de lui en
croyant faire le bien
on va faire une interview vérité on ne
bouge pas dans le single bien alors vous
êtes né en 45 j'ai commencé à courir
l'âge de 15 ans dans les kermesses et
tout de suite les amphétamines à des dès
le début pas tout de suite mais en
danger des mines alors vous dites
d'ailleurs quand on prend des en fait on
voi le mec tout petit comme ça
voilà en ce sens super mal en ce sens
superman et le problème c'est quand on a
mal calculé son coup après après la
descente est difficile comme superman
comme superman à prendre les moyens
malcom d'ipad madoui alors après donc à
23 ans devait arrêter parce que votre
père voulait trop vous poussez c'est ça
et c'est ça il était y croyez que tout
le monde pouvait venir champions c'est
vrai c'est pas la cas quoi il était
pharmacien mon oncle vous devez
chauffeur de car à ce moment là et vous
revenez dans le cyclisme comme soigneur
comme soit comme soigneur alors quand on
vous parle du dopage et on vous dit est
ce que vous croyez qu'on peut gagner
cinq tours de france à l'eau claire non
alors non bbc lyse en fait
et puis après ils ont arrêté à la mort
de simpson en 67 ils ont arrêté les
amphétamines on est plutôt passée du
côté des anabolisants les gens lisent
encore vous parler d'un pharmacien qui
habitait à pascal comme on dit pascal
vous allez vous servir chez lui passé
par là on est passés par l'arrière et
c'est un autre fournisseur quoi à
l'époque c'était facile pour ses liens
on apprend que le vélo c'est pire que
tout voilà moi mais ça c'est à l'époque
il ya vingt-six ya longtemps parce
qu'elle a pris il ya eu le pays
passe en classe il pas un petit rhume en
tout prix c'est tout ali bongo fils
habite pas un truc là n'ont pas vu ça
c'était le meilleur niveau
enfin vous appelez ça du grand nord
parce que je suis dit là je suis malade
il à cause du procès n'ont pas dit leurs
fournisseurs de dos n'ont même pas un
parent soigneur soigneur vous
transporter vous avez du mal à dire de
vous dites je rentre pas toujours tabou
dit pas je drague les cours et dit je
les prépare à le préparer
c'est très difficile dit cyrus usagers
quels seraient ses sept raids c'est très
dur dopage et non on le prépare ont
l'air si j'avais su je ne serais jamais
fait serré j'aurais dit que je faisais
du vélo j'étais con alors on n'y a pas
pensé à ça donc mais vous dites que les
coureurs il aime tellement ça a failli
il aimait tellement ça que j'étais
obligé de tenir les produits par devers
vous parce que sinon ils se mettaient
n'importe quoi il faut faire parce que
c'est vrai c'est un produit surtout le
dernier produit qui existe
on se sent tellement bien que voilà
alors des composants labeur c'est un
truc comme ça sérieusement pour ma
gouverne personnes
est ce que est ce que les journalistes
sportifs le savent et est ce que robert
chapatte le savez bien sûr tous ces gens
là l'ont su et qu'ils ont rien dit
pendant 35 ou 40 ou 50 ans ils sont
aussi coupables que vous bien qu on doit
tout le respect hardware chapin parce
que ça ne regarde pas ce que les gens le
nom mais c'est un ancien coureur dont
qui sait de quoi il parle donc mais
c'est la légende de ça donc mais tout le
journaliste sportive ils sont au courant
qu est ce qui se passe parce qu'ils sont
vivants mais ils sont jamais dans les
chambres et bombay le 10 pages sportives
pourquoi je lui sais quoi manger et j'en
ai parlé
boulot mais eux n'ont eux ils étaient la
peau pour parler de lui alors on nous a
toujours expliqué que le tour de france
d'un truc formidable formidable qui
monte des montagnes et un jour
d'apprendre sont tous des foncières
formidable demain on arrête la daube la
dope
ce seront toujours les mêmes qui sont
devant c'est en tous les cas je trouve
ça s'ils voulaient pour moi c'est un
petit peu comme la francisque de
mitterrand dire que tout le monde le
savait personne n'a parlé ou l'amitié de
mitterrand pour bousquet tout le monde
le savait personne à parler en lisant de
vos bouquins et puis d'autres bouquins
on s'aperçoit que les gens ni sportif
depuis 50 ans il savait qu'à dame
blanche de geminiani c'était la coke et
personne n'en parlait et je trouve
qu'ils font pas leur boulot c'est tout
ce que j'ai à dire je ne porte pas de
jugement moral peut-être peur de perdre
leur boulot est très parlant parce que
moi c'est pareil moi j'ai commencé à
parler mais j'ai fini dans ce milieu
alors en 93 vous commencé à bosser pour
festina vous allez chercher les flacons
à bordeaux qui arrive du portugal alors
votre femme quand même bon sens des
femmes
elle vous dit vous voulez vite suivi
fait de la place dans le frigo et elle
vous dit tout ça va mal finir dans
quelle votre femme attention toujours
est alors bon vous vous parlons
évidemment parler tout les docks
comprend l'oriel peau belge le pot belge
est un mélange assez complète et
poubelles
essayez le poubelle il ya en dedans à
c'est la recette du pont-belge c'est ce
que prennent les cyclistes il ya
amphétamines caféine antalgiques cocaïne
corticoïdes et on doit elle dans un
ballet tard et c'est un super speed ball
ils n'auraient pas besoin de toute sa
chérie ce soit alors dans votre premier
livre vous parlez de la cop16 et ils
font le championnat pour qu'ils sont
cinglés les mecs qui font les
championnats du monde de cyclisme en
colombie que font les mecs
pourquoi faire les championnats du monde
de cyclisme en colombie quand on sait ce
qu'on sait non mais c'était après cette
arrivée après après les championnats du
monde 8 juillet 98 vous faites arrêter à
la frontière donc avec des produits
dopants ce qu'ils voudraient mise en
examen alors vous faites arrêter quand
même payé 235 2 2 op aux 80 doses
d'hormones de croissance
60 doses de pente et stone que l'état il
a dit que c'était pour cette puce les
cartes hickory des amphétamines bon
genre d'émission quand vous passiez la
frontière tout le monde dit ouais ça lui
commence à dire inquiets ces jours là ce
jour là oui on dirait que j'avais un
sentiment jeter sur l'autoroute je dis
qu'est ce que je fais je passe la
frontière sur l'autoroute où je prends
le petit frontières et le dernier moment
le temps le dernier dernier moment je ne
quitte la route
je prends la petite route et voilà et
voilà je trouve je vois un monsieur la
barre à gauche
déjà sur le territoire français ils
m'arrêtent et bonjour monsieur durand
rien à dire rien a déclaré jeudi non pas
vraiment là c'était foutu et là je
sentais que c'était un coup monté
enfin je peux pas le dire mais j'ai le
sentiment parce que derrière le buisson
à droite de la route il y avait caché
une camionnette avec six derniers ils
sont sortis de leur camionnette ils ont
ouvert ma voiture ils ont enfin on peut
pas le dire j'ai le sentiment oui
l'affairé stinat comment raconter tout
le monde la connaît l'équipe était
exclue virenque pleurs les coureurs
abandonne enfin voilà et le tout 798 le
tour 99 vous pensez qu'il ya eu de la
défense toujours je pense oui à 19,99
était soi-disant le tour problèmes mais
ils ont quand même
fais le
moyenne le plus rapide détour il ya
quelque part il ya beaucoup de vent je
sais mais c'est très bien alors donc je
disais tout à l'heure avant de commencer
qu'il ya de la défonce et de l'enfance
comme vous l'avez très bien dit de très
belles phrases que ce que claude berri
alors moi je veux pas votre bouquin faut
lire page 43 6 min par tous page 108
c'est une bonne partout sans capote avec
carmen et page 220 c'est la partie
j'explique et qui est comme vous
affranchir un bouddha attendre il est
parti de 120h 220 c'est partout dès que
le mari consentant un donc ce qu'il faut
savoir mon cher bruel oui elle est
franche et envoya lycée qui carmen
carmen s'était départie de ses fils et
des groupies c'est comme dans la
politique c'est comme dans le show
business cd cd fille qui tourne autour
un peu comme les circuits de formule 1
sur ces défis qui suivent les retours à
l'agneau mari voilà elle adore les
coureurs elles vont tourner dans les
parkings autour des camions comme ça et
puis à 21h elles sont dans les chambres
d'hôtel je ne vais pas vous savez pas
franchement et à 22h20 sont les couloirs
et à 22 heures et sont dans les chambres
d'hôtel ltd 22h20 les carmen 1h15 il ya
plein de filles comme ça c'est à dire
que les peines avec nécessite pas ce
qu'on ne sait pas est ce qu'on découvre
dans le dans le livre de deux villes il
a dans ce bouquin c'est qu'on fait en
dehors de la défense il ya des le sec
sur des filles qui veulent se taper des
sportifs pour une raison à leur
incroyable elle fantasme sur les jambes
rasé dire que le fait que l ai pas que
ça aussi quand elle prend une fellation
à son parti pour la semaine
allez vous les dire que
heidi testostérone
c'est vrai marqueur des graminées ça
laisse rêveur
et lorsque ça l'état moi je me demandais
je me demandais toujours dans l'est a
fait détruire en battant siège et
regarder toujours en plein rêve pourquoi
tout le monde je voulais suivre le tour
chaque année on vous dit moi ma vie de
france de division suite du tour de
france est ce que tu es la première
année qui ma ville j'y vais chancel
pendant tout le temps sur le tour de
france est allée font payer toujours sur
le tour et j'ai compris un truc qu'on
soit trop souvent fait dans les villes
dans les étapes y aller il ya les ils
vont il faut cliquer les boîtes
échangistes sauvé ce nom on croyait que
c'était le tour de france en fait c'est
le tour des boîtes échangistes de loi en
ce sens il y en a pas partout
preview l'année ont fini la galère but
parce qu'il avait mal où tu sais mais
n'a rien à voir
alors que ceux ci étaient en vie avant
disait toujours faux pas baiser avant la
course a bien ça on disait trouver des
produits de niro dans raging bull avant
le avant le combat il est là et là en
fait mais c'est pas si hier le tour de
france où le champion du monde c'est
autre chose mais qui sont quand même pas
comment ce poids là mais si ça vient ça
vient et c'est beau le sport est alors
et d'autres révélations dans votre
bouquin il est d'abord que les filles
cyclistes se dope aussi parce qu'on
apprend c'est que les suiveurs il se
dope aussi c'est les mecs de la caravane
a dit attends j'ai me le borgne à faire
en bagnole aujourd'hui je m'en voyez y a
un casier grande en fait souligné
coralie et les pensionnés passe a connu
une grande carrière
robino non cela c'est que vous aussi
vous vivez plus size - vous êtes défense
et vous bat bien sûr et vous dites moi
pourquoi pas non évidemment
c'est pour ça qu'il dit maintenant je
peux mettre des chemises à manches
courtes et voilà maintenant vous êtes
cleanequity fière de moi je me suis en
sortie tout bas toute façon oui c'est ça
c'est bien je suis content oui avec un
douanier comme celle décrochée avec un
douanier n'aura bien sûr le doyen g
heureusement heureusement j'ai
heureusement je suis content je suis
content ce que vous dites vous en gros
et l'abrègement gros vous dites que bon
on va peut-être trouvé un moyen pour
voir le le paie aussi ce qui va se
passer l'air maintenant là le 20 juin
bon mais vous dites qu après il ya
d'autres trucs façon que les gendarmes
m'ont toujours moins vite que les
voleurs là que finalement il ya le pfc
il ya l'hémoglobine réticulé etc
finalement les mecs ils auront toujours
un tour d'avancé parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de pognon
donc les mecs ils trouveront toujours
des docks que les autres ne savent pas
découvrir voilà donc ces drogues a
drogué pour tous mais j'ai toujours
connu ça et sur trente ans de carrière
on a toujours essayé de sauver autre
chose ouais vous dis toute façon le jour
il nous faut lui faut évidemment c'est
de contrôler le dopage nous dit ce jour
là ce sera plus un sport ce sera un
spectacle spectacle comme aux états unis
il faut que le championnat à venir
annoncer la naissance sera pas plus mal
et ce sera moins dangereux
bien luis fernandes la france veut en
savoir plus
interview vérité
[Musique]
fait chaud qu'une fine fait déchirer la
gueule j'aime bien je le préviens alors
non pas du tout luis en 96 vous
déclariez à l'équipe magazine
j'attendrai le temps qu'il faudra mais
je suis convaincu que je reviendrai au
psg aujourd'hui vous regretter d'être
venu quelque chose est pas quelque part
quelque chose que je l'avais pensé je
l'avais imaginé c'est pas si rapidement
que ça puisque après avoir passé quatre
années comme celle que j'ai passé en
espagne avoir vécu dans un championnat
comme le championnat espagnol
je m'étais donné une année sabbatique un
peu dans le dans ce monde qui est un peu
un monde et le milieu du football qui a
énormément bougé vous il ya beaucoup de
choses qui qui bouge bon maintenant on
ne le fait pas alors non je regrette pas
du tout c est un club que j'aime et que
j'ai fait partie de moi alors est ce que
vous vivez la plus mauvaise période de
votre carrière d'entraîneur non non
parce qu'il ya il ya des moments
difficiles c'est éventuellement à la
télé ça arrive aussi un oui mais dans
les 8 années d'entraîneur depuis le
début
parfois j'ai eu des moments difficiles
et que bon bah les gens ne sont pas
censés savoir ne pas reconnaître à moi
de bien savoir les passer ces moments là
et pourquoi le psg gagne plus en fait
pour qu'elle ne gagne plus le pg je
crois qu'il ya eu quand on voit un peu
la situation du club et on voit un peu
ces dix dernières années à chaque année
a toujours un période un peu délicate
un peu difficile et le club a toujours
son mauvais passage et qu'on arrivera là
relativement à essayer de trouver la
solution à moi et je pense que
personnellement j'ai quelques idées
là-dessus bien
alors quand lors de la défaite le 10
février à auxerre vous avez déclaré que
peut-être de la malchance j'ai parlé de
corbeaux et de chats noirs et c'est vrai
que le 20 février contre le milan ac
égalisation à la dernière minute il ya
un mauvais sort contre le psg je ne
dirais pas qu'il ya un mauvais sort il
ya un an on peut dire que dans le sport
il ya des périodes comme ça qu'il faut
savoir analyser qu'il faut savoir
essayer de comprendre même si parfois on
essaie de se dire bon on a trouvé une
solution mais que le football le sport
en général il n'y a rien d'acquis mais
que ça aussi ça fait partie dans le
football de ces moments difficiles
qu'une équipe peut traverser un mauvais
sort parce que laurent ruquier a essayé
de désenvoûter le psg version démission
mardi dernier il a presque réussi la
presse que réussi il a presque réussi le
journal nu alors oui moi il a presque
réussi parce qu'on a fait un bon match
face à milan ouais et on dirait je
dirais plutôt que c'est sur ces matches
là qu'on travaille un peu sur pour
l'avenir ouais alors pour en revenir à
la ligue des champions compte tenu des
performances actuelles de l'équipe
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que ses
deux victoires en deux matches sont
possibles
oui oui oui tout est possible je dirais
que quand on voit l'équipe réalisé un
bon match face au milan ac en y mettant
de la qualité on y mettra un état
d'esprit on dit que la coupe d'europe ça
c'est un parfum un peu spécial ça les
joueurs aiment cette compétition là et
la joue parce qu'ils savent que c'est un
peu la vitrine c'est à dire que ces
joueurs là du psg ils se battent que
concéder des trucs un peu valorisant
encore la ligue des champions ça a ses
exceptions avec des champions ça
transforme ça ça motive ça s'est passé
s'est regardé dans
dans le monde entier et on a tous à y
gagner avec des champions c'est la coupe
d'europe c'est le c'est un des objectifs
bon c'était peut-être pas celui du pg
cette année c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
un quart de finale 1
alors il faut éventuellement il faut
retenir fois à la corogne contre la
corogne avec le psg ce sens et je sais
que vous dites on peut y arriver on peut
y arriver
ouais non c'est parce que j'ai gagné là
moi c'est que je crois que l'effectif où
l'équipe en réalisant ce qu'elle a
réalisé cette année tant elle est
capable de gagner à la corogne
est-ce qu'ils sont pas trop payés trop
gâté les joueurs du psg aujourd'hui je
ne dirais pas je le dirai pas comme ça
je dirais que le football en depuis la
loi bosman depuis le sait ces
changements c'est d'un étang et à un
bouleversement des données et il
faudrait s'y pencher mais bon en ce sont
des artistes des garçons qui essaye de
faire le mieux possible si on est con on
est trop payé dans le milieu du football
je dirais que dans d'autres professions
si on est trop payé réellement bien
pourquoi vous changer si souvent luis la
formation des pilotes
au programme énormément de compétition
quand tu as un effectif surtout quand en
un comme celui que tu as au paris
saint-germain tu as 25 joueurs qui sont
réellement où il ya de la qualité
tu obligé de faire un tourneur
l'entraînement terrenales de nos ex le
disais il ya pas très longtemps
pourtant il est deuxième du championnat
avec des options de gagner la coupe de
france la coupe de la ligue
il est en coupe d'europe et en
championnat l'an il est dans le vrai et
je pense aussi comme lui que quand tu as
beaucoup de compétition il faut aussi
penser à faire tourner un peu en effet
dû alors quand tu gagnes personnes
meurent et larry levan pas et quand tu
perds ça change
alors qu'on tente parle maintenant on va
te dire aussi sur la tactique tu change
souvent de système tactique tu joues
avec 3 avec 4 avec 5 les joueurs sont un
peu perdus mais ils sont censés être
professionnel aussi le joueur doit
s'adapter à toutes les situations
est ce que mon entraîneur on doit
s'adapter ci contre le milan ac je
m'aperçois que je joue dans un système
et que ça se passe mal à moins
d'interpréter le jeu à moins de changer
et le jour est capable d'analyser qu'il
faut changer le joueur a su le faire
face à milan c'est lorsque cinq ans
pourront rentrer un peu dans c dans ses
systèmes et les médias veulent savoir
quand je les vois à la télé et sur le
banc de touche c'est un vrai spectacle
arrêtez de le voir et parce que en tout
cas il y avait en main que j'ai une idée
son match et il a l'air sincère dans
l'image qu'on a vu tout à l'heure là
c'était une magnifique l'aller j'ai vu
le visage détruit par le vhc je suis
détruit
ça fait mal pour les jours parce qu'ils
le méritent pas un mérite pas de prendre
un but comme ça la minute quand on voit
ce qu'ils ont réalisé durant 90 autant
je peux être déçu après le match de
guingamp de la deuxième mi temps
lorsqu'on perd 3 à la maison je peux
être déçu parce que parce que c'est
qu'en formant peut-être il ya eu un
relâchement mais après une défaite après
un match nul comme suit 2
face au milan quand on prend un but de
costa et luiz mais fuit vers la place de
pour le psg un match nul parce que j'ai
vu quelque part tous les soirs quand il
commence il y encore un jour sans que le
pg gagne
ouais et ses duels alors est-ce que
pourquoi vous nous obligez pas anelka
parler à la presse
les médias se sont acharnés un peu sonné
cola je serai bon de dire que nicolas
c'est quand on le connaît bien quand on
le voit vivre au sein d'un groupe
c'est quelqu'un de très il est charmant
il est il est sympa il ya plus de cinq
sièges de son union qui profite à qui
oui mais alors justement confirmant à ça
quand ils vendent espagne qui fait un
contrat de sept ans il n'a pas eu
revenir un an après au pressage enfin
parce qu'il peut le rester c'est ans
là-bas et éventuellement il peut se
mettre vraiment tranquillement mais
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
ouais pour te dire ce qu'il allait s' il
avoir pour revenir jouer en france
footballeur parce que les artistes non
je pense moi moi j'ai une carrière
beaucoup plus longue
un autre extrait des carrières très bien
sûr une dizaine d'années ouais mais on
n'en gagne que pendant cinq ou six ans
si dans les cinq premières années des
moyens de pression à clarifier le revoir
l'année prochaine si vous n'êtes pas bon
sur le sujet par le coupe d'europe les
garder anelka quand même oui
ah ben quand il fait partie de ces
garçons sur lesquels on compte je crois
que c'est bien il est moins polluer
nancy paris c'est quand même un grand
club bressan est un club qui fait rêver
vous plaît le client en europe
quand on parle du précédemment en
espagne c'est un job qui qui aspire à
être hyper considéré en espagne d'une
bonne cote
maintenant c'est là qu'on va le manger
se seraient connus en france
oui je sais pas mal échangé cet appât
pour l'être bien est ce que laurent
perpère et compétents comme les crises
très compétent a vraiment ce que l'on
peut dire ce que j'ai à faire
hier que denisot comme président comme
ça je dirais qu'il est différent il a sa
méthode
perpère et quand même quelqu'un qui
laisse travailler son entraîneur et qui
le laisse faire ce qu'il a à faire et
que me laisse travailler tranquillement
alors les supporteurs ils sont pas
contents 1
je les ai rencontrés ya pas très
longtemps sont pas contents ils ont
rencontré avec ces gens est un bel
endroit
ils ont fait une banderole avec ww point
équipe de merde point fr et quand même
mais bon ça c'est le c'est un peu le et
puis sur le tard sur la route du camp
des loges il ya quelques temps les un
peu capables match avancé du dernier sur
la voiture de perpère aussi aux années
le cas qui prend aussi la sueur d'année
mais le président populaire et vous
allez rencontrer vient la rencontre des
supporters ce qui n'est réellement se
souvient acquis ce qui se cache et qui
richesse qu'il leur a dit fait ensemble
on s'est retrouvé à 300 400 supporters
on leur expliquait on leur a donné des
raisons de bon vin que la situation
n'était pas au mieux ouais c'est normal
qu'ils soient déçus mais il faut qu'on
reste solidaire
donc on reste unis elle a concentré
intérêts de suicide de 13% des
supporters donc il faudrait quand même
verrouillé l'histoire maintenant didier
interview vérité
le boeing
bien alors donc ben on va parler de vous
maintenant très sérieusement après ce
préambule sur la chine et romancière
chinoise
vous avez 28 ans vous êtes issu d'un
milieu aisé si deux professeurs
d'université et vous même vous êtes
diplômé de littérature la prestigieuse
université de fudan à shanghai alors le
premier scandale que vous avez fait en
chine s'il en est sorti le premier
bouquin qui s'appelait les cris perçants
du papillon vous allez faire un
happening vous exposiez 7 steve blanc où
il y avait une nouvelle écrite sur les
slips et votre photo comme signature
c'est vrai que ça fait un moment chez
moi un chauffeur de mois tandis que les
femmes chinoises je pense qu'elles sont
contentes de ce que j'ai dis pas ce que
je sers en quelque sorte à leur porte
parole
voilà une sorte de virginie despentes
chinoise mais ce que je veux dire à bien
moi j'essaie de ne pas lire les sous
titres en même temps bien alors ce
bouquin à shanghai
baby donc c'est l'histoire de coco parce
qu'ils prennent dénonce à ces modes de
prendre d'élan coco comme coco chanel
elle a une copine s'appelle madonna donc
voilà c'est ces modes là bas voilà à la
chanteuse ou way judas et coco à 25 ans
elle vit à shanghai et elle partage sa
vie entre thiam tchad qui est un jeune
chinois qui est un puissant pour le
pauvre il est victime et il est il est
déjà grande donc quand on est jeune qui
de façon on est impuissant même si on
n'est pas un puissant donc sa 7ème
siècle qu'il aime beaucoup qu'il
idolâtre ebi marque qui est un allemand
et qui a un énorme sexe pas de maître
avec qui elle baise c'est frénétiquement
coco l'héroïne
biographique c'est plutôt une espèce de
semi auto graphie c'est fatigant donc
effectivement le livre a été censurée
sarthe et scandale parce
qu'effectivement les chinoises sont
souvent ça arrive et s'ils ne sont pas
satisfaites et avec les étrangers bas le
connaissent un plaisir peut-être un
petit peu supérieure enfin tout le monde
le sait vous dites vous même tout le
monde le sait là bas il faut pas le dire
encore mois l'écrire voilà donc un peu
mis les pieds dans le plat tradition
chinoise on peut faire certaines choses
mais on ne peut pas en parler
je pense que ça fait partie de nos
traditions orientales voilà donc je
tapais des allemands avec un sexe énorme
c'est possible mais il faut pas le dire
et pas l'écrire voilà ce nous ce ne
comprends pas je 323 alors c'est
tellement l'a fait fantasmer parce
qu'elle voit alors le mec il est marié
qu'une écolo qui s'occupe de la
protection de l'environnement il a rien
à nazis allemands 1 mais elle fontanes
quand même sur le côté un peu parce 323
les femmes aiment avoir dans leur lit
des fascistes dans les bottes de cuir
résonne à leurs oreilles ça ça fait un
peu trip cuir toit c'est un peu un peu
et des cuirs oui je pars en est ce qu il
faudrait pas comprendre que schaaf les
sa magie licence art bons sont leurs
propres fantasmes
bien sûr certaines désir même faire
l'amour avec nos pairs déjà page 81 sa
commande
j'imagine les yeux germanique bleus
cruel et féroce vous excite pas qu'il
est en costume nazi avec des bottes et
un monde coûte vraiment tout de cuir
alors oui c'est ça mais ça va cartonner
en allemagne peut cartonner oui ils
n'ont pas eu la même chose que nous a
les clés voilà exactement les années 40
bruce un peu plus loin alors oui voilà
alors c'est tellement donc comme je les
dis un organe impressionnant et alors
elle seule l'héroïne coco cela fait
crier de douleur fait pour ça que en
fait que se trouve dans une situation
délicate entre le désir et la souffrance
alors que toutes les femmes cherchaient
à les combiner ensemble
exactement donc elle elle continue
malgré la taille du sexe et la phrase et
j'ouvre les yeux avec un mélange de
haine et d'amour dans le regard assez
chaud un mal à marcher science mais il
ya plein de trucs qui marchent sur mort
du père alors donc il ya des siennes
véritablement les téléphones goûter
enfin pas vous mais l'héroïne de coco
est téléphone à thiennes khan l'oncle
pop qui jane donc il est impuissant les
devants et pendant ce temps marc lech
son sexe à travers sa petite culotte
jusqu'à les oublier qu est ce qu date
c'est bien la littérature chinoise
d'aujourd'hui non mais là ça y est on
est dedans je voudrais savoir si les
hommes français
ça leur arrive de lécher leurs femmes
[Musique]
j'ai jamais fait l'amour personnel des
trucs vers un jour y arriver à sa
maintenance à la culotte c'est vrai que
bon c'est après la chine et le bouquin
c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient trois
exemplaires en même temps dire bien bon
pas à la fin page 306 je reste là parce
que je suis noir prélasser l'attention
c'est pour sa marque la marque par
différents vous savez ça parce que ça
peut pas durer une histoire comme ça
atteint positionne jeanne humeur bien
évidemment il y aussi le pot
d'échappement bien sûr tu vois alors
prenez direction les réactions en chine
le vif pilonné donc détruit complètement
détruit et puis alors poursuivi vous
avez été poursuivi par des fous qui
voulait absolument venger l'affront fait
à l'honneur national parce que bien
évidemment les chinois c'est vrai dire
ça ne va pas là bas alors là elle est
obligée de rester habiter la chine trois
fois sortir enfin plutôt je ne sais pas
encore mais j'ai entendu dire qu'il ya
aussi un écrivain
franco chinois qui s'appelle quotidien
qui éteindront décrue ben ouais arriver
le prix est d'ailleurs j'ai obtenu ma
offert un livre j'écris harriman non
mais c'est la dissolution du lien il
avait été honni il habite dans une tour
en banlieue la somalie ferme soit le
format est d'avoir votre bouquin se
changer les idées
chambly
[Musique]
bon ici de michaël blanc qui est
condamné à perpétuité à la prison à bali
pour détention de cabanis et vous êtes
nombreux à les visiter son site pour
pour l'aider ce soir voici
voici le père de michaël blanc
[Musique]
jean claude blanc bonsoir moi baho de
vous voir on est moins de voir votre
fils mais on espère que ça viendra
bientôt en tous les cas
quelles sont les dernières nouvelles de
michael c'est toujours statu quo statu
quo la situation judiciaire actuelle
c'est le recours en cassation
voilà c'est prévu pour quand date butoir
ce serait le 1er mai le 1er mai hélène
votre femme est là bas oui et vous ici
vous coordonnez le comité le comité de
soutien on va parler de tout ça
interview vérité en ébauchant régulière
[Musique]
bien vous vous êtes artisan en
haute-savoie votre épouse était employée
comptable vous êtes vous n'êtes pas les
moyens financiers inépuisable donc c'est
vrai que ça va être très compliqué pour
vous en ce moment d'organiser la défense
et la sortie de votre fils alors lui les
bains michael un cap2 cuisinier puis il
a travaillé dans divers restaurants en
suisse en belgique et en 95 il est
besoin d'évasion
il est parti en malaisie est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous aviez eu peur de ça quand
il est parti et qui vous a dit je pars
en asie quand même l'asie c'est
inquiétant non pas spécialement
il est parti tout d'abord en inde et
après en malaisie donc il a travaillé un
moment malaisie puis à manille alors
belle il faut dire aujourd'hui ce que
c'est devenu parce que c'est vrai qu'on
a une image de ben ali
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une espèce de
saint tropez ben ali un ccc la jet set
jagger belmondo marc lavoine
jean luc delarue ophélie winter a
lorsqu'il hôtels de luxe des bungalows
beaucoup de calmes et pas seulement du
cabanis donc faut savoir ce que c'est
devenu aujourd'hui lien lui il arrive
là-bas michael ils travaillent sur des
chantiers de bateaux de plaisance et
puis monter un magasin de vêtements vous
aviez des nouvelles régulièrement de vie
oui pas spécialement mais bon
une fois par mois oui une fois par mois
est biffé des voyages pour
approvisionner son magasin de vêtements
et un jouet part en inde alors là les
versions divergent un peu parce que il
ya le fait qu'il soit parti en inde pour
acheter des vêtements propres pour
approvisionner son magasin et puis à une
autre version qui dit qu'il est parti
faire de la moto en à la vraie version
c'est quoi enfin d'après vous ben en
fait il est je pense qu'il était parti
chercher des vêtements et puis comme
comme ça se passe dans ces pays là on
doit sortir du pays pour le visa pour
refaire les visas donc était parti en
inde et en a profité pour faire un tour
dans le sud de l'inde voila voila et en
obtenant donc il a pris uniquement de
plongée complet qu'un ami lui a remis à
même ce dénommé philippe donc les
franco-israéliens qui lui dit est ce que
tu peux emporter ses bouteilles de
plongée à ba vi est ce que c'était
vraiment un ami ou est-ce que c'était
une rencontre de voyage c'est une
connaissance je pense comme ça se passe
dans tous ces pays là on rencontre
quelqu'un qu'on connaît par son prénom
ne comprenais pas vraiment mais ça
devient vite un ami donc il ay lui a
fait confiance
et voilà ils leur amener son matériel et
donc le matériel était complet et donc
de bouteilles de plongée qui renfermait
soi-disant de la drogue voilà donc il y
avait à l'intérieur la douane a passé
les bouteilles de plongée aux rayons x
ils ont trouvé 189 boulettes et 178
petits paquets de haschich donc au total
ça fait 3 kg 8
alors effectivement bon la question se
pose ça change rien à la situation
est ce qu'il a été piégé par un escroc
ou est-ce que lui il a vu là dedans un
trafic juteux pour se faire un peu
d'argent je dire c'est pas non plus
extrêmement criminelle pour nous michael
est innocent en fait il s'est fait
piéger mais il faudrait savoir à qui
profite le crime
ouais voilà donc lui il lui dit qu'il
n'a pas assisté à la fouille c'est à
dire que lui dit déjà trois ans - on dit
qu'il y avait du haschich dans les
bouteilles
moi j'ai pas assisté au moment où on a
sorti la chiche des bouteilles donc déjà
l'huile des pâtes et moins de ce dont on
l'accusé sont tous les cas en fait il
n'était pas encore passé à la douane il
avait deux sacs un été complètement
détruit l'autre contenait le matériel
avait une croix dessus et qu'il a saisi
le sac de douaniers lorrains l'ont
rattrapé il n'avait encore pas passer la
douane on m'a dit quelque chose dans les
bouteilles et ça a duré plusieurs heures
il avoue les délices et les bouteilles
on l'a dit non non ils ont embarqué les
bouteilles parce qu'en regardant à
travers les bouteilles on peut voir
quand même well par le trou on peut voir
mais dont ils ont percé ciller après
alors ce philippe qui lui avait confié
ses bouteilles
il a jamais été recherchées finalement
j'ai pas où il est je peux et l'idée
excusez moi mais l'idée d'engager un
détective privé pour le retrouver
oui j'avais pensé je pense que ce serait
facile de le retrouver mais ça ne les
intéresse pas du tout intéresse pas les
balles le 28 décembre 1999 femme hélène
reçoit un fax du consul de france 2 à
denpasar donc est la capitale de ben ali
et laisse passer les fêtes avant de vous
prévenir que je crois vous êtes séparés
non et eu tellement choqué c'est ça je
sais pas quand vous dire a reçu un fax
ça devait être le 28 elle avait eu deux
coups de téléphone avant elle a posé
mais alors il se retrouve en garde à vue
michael donc à bali 27 par cellule sans
eau ni toilettes
des fois on amène des gens qui ont été
blessés par balles enfin bon c'est ces
pays là s'est il est là au milieu du
sang il n'a pas le droit de faire de
promenade il ya un premier procès où là
les avocats
votre femme assistait au procès mais
alors quand elle arrive là bas elle voit
le prétoire que la salle du tribunal les
avocats commis d'office qui sont
assoupis le juge qui
dehors et le procureur qui réclame le
swing de morges c'est ce qu'a fait 4
depuis le début d'appel traducteur en
fait il ya eu 6 et un traducteur commis
d'office mais qui nous parlaient la
guerre du mal à comprendre s'il le
souhaite
oui parce que la base qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le cannabis est un signe le
haschich et assimilés à une drogue dure
dire que pour eux c'est comme trafic
d'héroïne ou trafic de cocaïne donc ya
pas un soutien des autorités françaises
justement c'est que les autorités
françaises il ya un consul de france la
barre peut le dire qu'ils se bougent pas
tellement ou quoi c'est un comble une
auto rien voilà oui c'est ça c'est un
consul honoraire c'est à dire qu'il ait
fait d'autres choses imaginons fait pas
que ça quand on est consul honoraire
vingt deux activités oui alors le
procureur réclame la peine de mort pour
pour pour ce à quoi donc
et le verdict en fait et transformé par
le juge
ça devient perpétuité enfin perpétuité
quand même c'est beaucoup et même les
balinais sont surpris quand même les
gens là bas il dit c'est pas bizarre
quoi parce qu' il dise l'indonésie veut
faire un exemple c'est ça a sûrement à
la c'est pour ça je vous dis à qui
profite le crime
ils veulent montrer le centre ville
voilà les américains leur disent lutter
contre la drogue
donc ils disent voilà on va montrer
qu'on lui tend temps en temps ils en
prennent un comme ça et puis le le
condamne à mort et quand c'est pas
avancer l'histoire du midnight express à
l'histoire locale
à paris le ministère des affaires
étrangères fait pas grand chose hein ils
se bougent pas tellement et alors quand
on voit ce qui se passe là bas par
exemple un colonel indonésien pour
comparer un qui a décapité de
commerçants chinois qu'il avait volée il
prend trois ans
un balinais qui avait violé et tué une
fillette il prend quatre ans donc tu
vois la différence et lui pour trois
kilos 8,2 de chypre en 1 permet quoi
clairement une personne s'était arrêtée
avec 165 kg de haschisch
ouais il aime 15 ans ouais c'est ça mais
c'est sa soixante
peut-être capsule d'ecstasy ces quatre
ans ouais tu es une personne c'est un
homme voilà bah oui ce qui pourrait leur
dire ce soir là la france pour le moment
a enfin je sais pas vous allez nous le
dira mais la france est enfin l'état
français a fait quoi
c'est à dire que pendant qu'ils aient le
procès c'est une ingérence ouais donc
ils ne peuvent pas être trop agir mais
pour y suivre quand même la sphère web
on leur demande dans tous les cas on ne
lâchera pas ajouté je dis donc vous
remplissez pas les moyens de payer la
rançon en dessous des fois ça peut
s'arranger
par exemple si donné un million de
francs on est à peu près sûr que si vous
donnez un million de francs mais pas
avec dix ans quand même ça ça reste à la
fois cher et l'ont enfin disons que ça
serait une façon de le faire est de le
faire sortir
généralement les gens qui se font choper
là bas j'étais arrivé à des types du
sentier qui sont fait arrêter l'année
dernière là bas ils ont donné 150 mille
balles trois cent mille balles ils sont
repartis tout de suite voilà et vous le
million vous n'avez pas toutes façons
donc voilà alors lieu un deuxième procès
encore pire que le premier parce que le
premier déjà c'était pas terrible avec
le juge qui dormait le deuxième procès
c'est l'appel donc c'est passé à huit
clos en là ils ont appris que le procès
avait eu lieu hier que l'as tu veux
c'est pire que tout ce que tout le monde
a appris que la posture et avait eu lieu
à huis clos et que la peine de
perpétuité avait été confirmée c'est ça
c'est ça alors il reste la cassation
passé en train de se préparer un petit
peu peur que ça se passe comme l'appelle
vous avertissent pas mais en fait le
procureur demande toujours la peine de
mort toujours la peine de mort c'est pas
possible
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aider je fais bien son vietnam en or
mais en
on est tout à fait prêt à vous aider dit
nous une rançon d'un million francs à la
rigueur si l'argent pourrait le libérer
mais si c'est l'argentin millions de
français nous avait demandé
on a entendu parler d'un million 4 pour
descendre de la peine de mort à la
prison à vie
donc on a refusé de passer de faire ça
et puis donc c'est déjà descendu mais si
on leur propose de l'argent ils vont ils
en ont des cendres un petit peut alors
commencer quoi donc sa part la pression
médiatique que les médias peuvent faire
sur le gouvernement
c'est le plus important gouvernement
français sipa plus problème c'est qu'il
ya des gens
excusez moi mais c'est déjà un peu
susceptible donc si on n'intervient ils
vont dire celle intériale isme non plus
américain ce coup ci mais français ils
interviennent dans nos affaires on est
un pays
voilà on est un pays souverain à
l'indonésie donc les français viennent
nous expliquer comment il faut le juger
les gens ils ont qu'à s'occuper des
problèmes cachés eux etc ne faut pas non
plus les énerver c'est ça qui est
compliqué c'est à dire que il faut
clairement fasse pression sans pour
étant les les énervés parce que prit
alors la question c'est comment leur
faire plaisir pour qu'ils le lâchent
oui parce que même là aussi c'est
l'argent ils demanderont toujours plus
c'est qu'on peut faire jean-claude c'est
très difficile je pense que
y'a qu'la politique puisse faire quelque
chose on s'aperçoit que il est vraiment
otages et on sait pas qui est ce que ça
peut arranger le cas d'un week-end mais
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu sceptique je
veux faire déjà scellé sur le site
internet pour se renseigner le plus de
beaucoup de gens ils vont après son
enseigne et à deux pas du site internet
elle s'écrit sur l'écran pendant que je
le dis c'est magique c'est près de 200
mille connexions
ça représente à peu près 1700 connexions
par jour depuis deux mois problème c'est
que au niveau politique ils ont des
désormais aussi les hausses pas trop
bouger on sent que suivant les parties
le servir de michael vous êtes un argent
bien sûr voilà on va s'organiser je
crois qu'il ya un ccp à quelque chose on
peut
oui un compte bancaire est ouvert au nom
de week-end qui est sur le net ou si on
peut voir tout ça
ben voilà c'est comme ça qu'on peut
aider déjà 100 de l'argent bloqué des
bons avocats des bons interprètes et
puis peut-être pour payer une rançon
merci monsieur blanc sec
à la fin de sa vie dans les dernières
années de sa vie
françois mitterrand avait un bon copain
[Musique]
c'est georges marc benamou
georges marc benamou bonsoir c'est vrai
qu'à la fin de sa luge est très copain
avec françois mitterrand sont pas si
c'est le moment
c était son confident disons qu'on dise
à vous et tessa est aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt ça
bien vous publié chez plon un livre qui
s'appelle jeune homme vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez
c'est commencer georges-marc je ne fais
pas pour ans ici on fait pour soi
d'habitude dans mais je vous le dis vous
faites les autres le font par politesse
mais c'est bien je surveille sur les
possibles même les rappeurs le fond
alors quand vous lisez leurs rapports
gabriel de jean d'ormesson ou françois
mitterrand par l'ats jean d'ormesson du
lobby juif
vous savez que c'est vrai puisqu'il vous
l'avez dit il à employer ce mot là je le
raconte dans ce livre
dans une conversation qui situe environ
15 jours avant la conversation avec avec
jean d'ormesson
mais je ne suis pas d'accord avec
l'interprétation qui en a été fait on
peut pas en conclure que mitterrand
était antisémite
on va en parler interview vérité bah oui
le titre jeune homme vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez ses références à un
repas au restaurant la mare et à paris
dans le xviième vous êtes avec françois
mitterrand danielle mitterrand qui a
d'autres d'autres personnes j'ai pas
envie de citer alors à une table à côté
il ya papon maurice papon donc qui ne
dîne pas avec nous les jeunes jean pas
avec vous vous vous dites comme ça vous
vous apercevez papon au fond de la salle
et vous dites
et dire que ce [ __ ] dinan ville pas de
réponse de mitterrand pas de réponse de
sa femme
et dire que il a mis le même zèle à
mettre des déportés dans des trains à
bordeaux que pour faire jeter des
algériens dans la seine en 61
c'est vrai un silence bien sûr c'est
vrai silence
vous rajoutez heureusement qui sera
bientôt jugé hélas danielle mitterrand
justement le scoop un peu l'un tenait
elle dit à devant vous elle dit à
mitterrand mais papon il était très
sympa avec toi du temps de
l'observatoire
donc lhi la fusille du regard évidemment
pas ce que dit quand même elle et
gaffeuse maman il se retourne vers vous
avec un air terrible et il vous dit
vous ne savez pas de quoi vous parlez
jeune homme est donc comme vous le
raconter avec beaucoup de mépris vous
dise à la mitraille commence
mais qu'est ce qui vous dit 10e qui l'a
longtemps souvent répéter cinquante ans
après on ne peut pas comprendre
cinquante ans après on ne peut pas tirer
un vieillard de son lycée ce qu'il
disait en cette scène est allé le
traîner en justice
c'est sa réticence à vouloir ouvrir les
placards de l'histoire et du bon on a
fait l'épuration elle a été bien faite
elle a été trop fatale a été mal faite
ne résoudront pas les plaies du passé
alors ça peut être une position de chef
d'état est ce que c'est la position de
notre génération je ne crois pas mais
finalement tout le monde a dit ça et le
général de gaulle le premier de gaulle
il a laissé pas pour en place 661 quand
il jette des arabes dans la seine par
définition c'était de gaulle le présent
dans le public
oui enfin il c'est plus compliqué il le
laisse en place à la libération
d'ailleurs indiscutablement parce que
finalement de gaulle préféré avoir des
bons préfets ou sous-préfets vichyste
parce que des communistes ou des
résistants quand il était trop dangereux
on les expédiera en indochine d'ailleurs
cela donc on laisse en place la france
de vichy contrairement à ce qu'on pense
au fusil quelques stars on emprisonne
guitry etc
mais l'essentiel des élites qui a été
affichée c'est pour ça que le procès
fait la mi temps est assez injuste parce
qu'il est né parmi d'autres et il sait
plus comment un mal connu que les autres
mais l'essentiel de la france était à
vichy c'est ce que j'appelle l'atlantide
dans mon livre
ida le concept on va y venir alors je
veux rester sur ce dîner parce qu'à la
fin de de ce dîner quand pape on s'en va
du restaurant il fait un signe discret à
mitterrand et c'est ça qui vous a là
vous comprenez d'un seul coup la
connivence qui entre ces anciens de
vichy d'une certaine façon il ya un
monde oui c'est le concept de
l'atlantide ya moins disparu à vichy le
10 juillet 40 se précipitent toute la
france les administrations ce qu'il en
reste
l'inspection des finances inspection des
finances on parle aujourd'hui des
inspecteurs des finances mais la vraie
naissance au pouvoir de l'inspection des
finances et vichy la préfectorale
l'armée en fait tout ça était à vichy
alors à partir de tas à l'inter de vichy
avec des familles le concept de
mitterrand et qui l'emploie cette
explosion qui l'emploie pour la première
fois lors de ce dîner
il y avait 2
tu es gorille à vie s'il est mal
embarqué bien arriver mitterrand était
10 est il un mal embarquée bien arriver
dans un accent de vérité bien arriver en
43 et puis les mal embarquée mme à
l'arrivée cela avait été peut-être ou
moins malins ou moins moreau ou moins
courageux mais finalement c'est laisser
la bourgeoisie qui sauf qu'ils sauvent
les meubles quoi les soudards de la
collaboration ils vont crever qu'on sait
c'est assez singulier on doit sentir
dans votre concept d'atlantide c'est
formidable merci non mais c'est vrai
parce que c'est exactement ça et
mitterrand vous le découvrez d'un seul
coup comme la figure centrale d'un
réseau d'anciens vichyste auquel il rend
des services l'année d'un an non il faut
être précis c'est pas c'est pas la
figure centrale d'un réseau d'anciens
mucistes il ya une souche politique qui
est à vichy qui est un anti gaullisme de
droite il ya des relations qui se nouent
vichy car c'est en être un jeune homme
très lent c'est finalement très
séduisant et beaucoup de gens se
raccroche à lui lui se crée des liens
mais il n'est pas et après guerre il
recycle un certain nombre de vichy il
est pas le réseau central il refuse
d'ailleurs assez courageusement il
s'occupe
ils refusent de venir gaulliste assez
courageusement parce qu'il pourrait
rentrer dans le gaullisme comme chaban
delmas le comme couve de murville et
finalement se blanchir il décide de
faire sa vie sans de gaulle alors dans
son cabinet il ya des anciens vichysme
il ya aussi georges dayan et des
résistants donc tout ça est un milieu
dans cette république paraît complexe
par rapport aux autres membres aux
autres atlante puisque les atlantides il
visite les prisons il retrouve du boulot
il explique dans killers et sociale
cades résistance enfin il est quand même
ce que je sais ce que je pense je ne
crois pas que ce soit une fidélité
idéologique que c'est le côté
bizarrement bon bon bon gars demi mais
vous dites dans votre bouquin de gier il
ya une tendresse il a une tendresse pour
ces collabos qui sont en prison ou la
menthe sa soeur qui a été au collège léo
question j'ai lu une tendresse de celle
que balzac à pour les réprouvés d'ancien
régime
alors on aime on aime 20 bêtes un hochet
qui monte à la surface et picardes et
s'en occuper des autres
clairement il sort des villes est servie
navigables oui
pourquoi il a refusé toujours toute
allégeance au gaullisme par orgueil il
me dit un jour cette phrase pleine de
vérité j'avais décidé en 45 de faire
carrière dans l'anti conformisme en fait
tout le monde se précipite vers le
gaullisme tout le monde aller au guichet
la différence plus création essaiera
donc qui sait lire où est ce que je vais
trouver ma place et c'est vrai que c'est
pas quentin est orgueilleux comme il
l'était c'est pas sa place et puis une
deuxième interprétation qui est la
mienne dans ce livre et qui fait partie
d'une conversation d'octobre 1995
c'est ce fameux rendez vous le premier
rendez vous avec de gaulle toute sa vie
il a raconté dont ça se passe en
décembre 1943 le joli terran arrive par
des circuits d'avion absolument
impossible et il est face à de gaulle et
toute sa vie il a raconté de gaulle a
été très antipathique ça s'est très mal
passé il y avait de l'électricité dans
l'air il a voulu me faire tuer après etc
et tout ça finalement je le découvre en
avec dans une conversation et le colonel
passy un certain nombre d'historiens en
attestent il l'a beaucoup aux olives et
il en a fait le socle de sa légende
rebelles à 27 ans contre de gaulle en
fait je crois que j'ai une vraie
humiliation et plus rien debout s'est
pas mal passé mais tu mitterrand comme
on dit un n'a pas été calculé par de
boules 1 et je crois qu'il ya ça ça y
est la manière donc les gaullistes on
parlait de mitterrand ce mot c'est me
tran huy cette manière négligent écrasé
ben oui il a dû l'appeler mimi tran il a
dû être unique jusque là jusqu'à ce que
vous en parlez tous les tous les dieux
hamel j'espère les catherine mais état
d'une opposition fronde
quant à elle été fondatrice de près de
beaux livres d'arriérés et je le
rappelle mais c'est ce qu'ils demandent
à tous raconté pendant des années et
c'est vrai qu'à un moment de sa vie il
me dit vous savez ça c'est pas si mal
passé lendemain il doit leurs skis se
mettaient en paix avec sa conscience s
qui rectifie encore un peu d'histoire il
a souvent écrit fier parce que là la
date la durée
e le fait qu'ils aient freiné ou pas
freiné enfin lilas il a beaucoup varié
cette histoire il dit en avant contre si
vous vous dites ont à raconter des
bêtises sur cette rencontre presque plus
étonnant dans votre bouquin quand même
c'est quand tu parles de vichy fait à
vie alors à pétain a tenté un vieillard
un peu dépassée mais magnifique
mitterrand aimait ça il y avait ça quand
il a déposé il a persisté à déposer
cette gerbe sur la tombe de pétain en 92
j'ai eu cette conversation avec lui
prenez ces installations c'est pétain
c'est verdun verdun c'est le plus grand
traumatisme de l'histoire française avec
la shoah dit il un million
trois cent mille morts c'est ça laisse
des traces dans le pays
je lui dis mais le pétain de 40 oblitère
le pétain de verdun qui est considérable
et je crois qu'il fait partie d'une
génération c'est ça notre divergence où
il pensait que verdun c'était aussi
important que 40
il était sur la ligne que décrit henri
amouroux 40 millions de pétainistes
c'est très curieux c'est très curieux
péan raconte sa fascination de jeunes
hommes quand ils le voient pour la
première fois au casino de vichy comme
ça il ya des lettres exalté et je crois
que quand on est vieux et c'était un
vieil homme d les souvenirs du cortex
jeunes remontent à la surface ne vais
probablement mais c'était pas la
fidélité idéologiquement ne l'était pas
c'est plus sentimental qu'idéologique
c'est sa jeunesse sa bohème les épaules
de danielle darrieux à un couvre au bord
de l'allier la [ __ ] et puis la
découverte durant il semble à l'ags et
toute la france toute la france et là
sur un kilomètre carré
il parle de bousquet enfin vous parlez
de bousquet donc mitterrand regrette que
la carrière de bousquet a été brisée à
l'âge de 35 ans il regrette la façon
dont bousquet a été abattu par un
christian didier curieux c'est curieux
et puis le lobby juif donc on y arrive
on découvre que son plus grand ennemi
politique finalement contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a pu penser c'était
klarsfeld
oui merci serge j'en ai parlé avec la
salle j'ai rencontré en faisant slip
j'ai essayé de reconstituer ce qui
s'était passé pour moi et c'est
finalement la trame de ce livre il ya
une guerre de la mémoire elle commence
le 16 juillet 1992 au monument du vel
d'hiv c'est le 50e anniversaire de la
rafle des juifs de paris mitterrand
vient c'est la première fois qu'un
président français vient c'est un
événement énorme et il est lu badinter
s'interpose dans un assez beau discours
que certains ont pu contester
et là je crois que c'est le premier choc
c'est une manif ou lu en partie par
serge klarsfeld qui a un objectif
politique
il est finalement de faire reconnaître
les responsabilités françaises dans
l'holocauste il l'écrit la digue dans 70
qu'on peut dire pour les téléspectateurs
pour que tout le monde je suis bien
et que klarsfeld connaissait le passé un
peu maréchaliste dix ans de mitterrand
et qui s'en sert comme une épée de
damoclès pour lui faire accepter
certaines choses
oui oui le père de clara elle n'était
dans un réseau d'ailleurs assez proche
de celui de mitterrand
et quand quand mitterrand fleuri la
tombe de pétain à l'île d'yeu ce que
vous êtes tous les présidents de la
république
tout le monde l'avait fait tout le monde
l'avait fait enfin le de gaulle l'art
est instituée en 67 parce que c'est le
50e anniversaire de verdun pompidou l'a
fait une fois ou deux giscard une fois
ou deux mitterrand était disons plus
acide du mal à vraiment alors que fait
klarsfeld il oblige mitterrand sous la
pression parce qu'il a il a des dossiers
d'une certaine façon à faire la journée
commémorative de la rafle du vel d'hiv
le 16 juillet ça se passe pas tout à
fait comme ça mitterrand s'obstinent ils
disent que la seule menace
bien sûr je vais plus m 2 de de gerbe
sur la tombe de pétain je la mettrais
surtout te les tombes de tous les
maréchaux de 14-18 et finalement la
maladresse de mitterrand fait que la
crise est i'll kill effectivement accède
à la demande de la première demande de
serge klarsfeld cette journée de
commémoration du salarié tout tourne
autour du 16 juillet puisque la guerre
de la mémoire elle se finit le 16
juillet 1995 trois ans plus tard et là
c'est chirac qui est président et il
fait le discours que klarsfeld attendait
que mitterrand n'a pas couché les noms
pendant ces trois ans il ya une vraie
guerre entre mitterrand d'une part une
partie des responsables de la communauté
juive des intellectuels à votre déjeuner
georges malgré le mot ici ça qui plaît
et qui est intéressant c'est ça la
phrase jeune homme ne savait pas elle
parle et c'est finalement la guerre de
deux générations la guerrière de 2,2
moral et c'est ça que j'ai observé
d'ailleurs sans vouloir faire de
jugement de valeur parce que tout ça est
très complexe
mais pourquoi il n'a pas accepté de
reconnaître la culpabilité de la france
dans vichy il l'a fait il avait la
position il avait une position gaulliste
puisque de gaulle avait aujourd'hui
c'est ça la france n'étaient pas fichés
l'été à londres donc il y avait une
position et l'agilité en quelques petits
pas fait je crois que les gens de cette
génération était très emmerder on peut
pas ils ont essayé et tout le monde a
essayé de cacher ce qui s'était passé
pendant 40 ans on en parle beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup depuis dix ans pendant
40 ans on n'a pas parlé effectivement la
chape de plomb gaulliste et
effectivement il faut aussi
ne pas tomber dans le piège dans lequel
tombent parfois serge klarsfeld que par
ailleurs je respecte qui est de dire les
responsabilités de la france et les
mêmes que celles de l'allemagne
le français allemands tous à l'eau tous
des porteurs qu'il faut dire c'est que
la france avait perdu la guerre jorge
marque la différence quand même ce qu'il
faut toujours bien rappeler ses caviars
été envahie par l'allemagne tire il est
aujourd'hui difficile quand on est
envahi par un pays plus fort que soi de
faire ce qu'on veut un double malentendu
entre dix ans la france de mitterrand et
la communauté juive pendant 40 ans on a
gagné on n'a pas parlé de l'holocauste
ont à cacher on a caché le
responsabilité de la police on a caché
les responsabilités administratives
on a caché tout ça et d'une certaine
ailleurs il ya une vraie blessure dans
la communauté
il faut dire que la nation elle a été
amputée d'une partie de son c'est marc
andré ça la france ne l'a pas accepté ce
qui fait le chagrin des juifs
je crois aussi qu'il ya un autre chagrin
qui le chagrin de la france qui est que
l' empire la deuxième puissance mondiale
s'est effondrée comme un château de
cartes de manière inimaginable en huit
semaines deux mois entre le 10 mai le
jour de l'offensive allemande et le 10
juillet où la république est abolie en
deux mois la deuxième puissance mondiale
s'effondre dans la honte avec des
ministres qui partent en pleine nuit
oubliant leurs dossiers la panique
généralisée et que ce traumatisme la cet
effondrement la de la france puis
d'ailleurs ensuite la guerre d'algérie
sas a été en tout cas cet effondrement
une blessure terrible aussi pour la
france qui a qui a rendu possible vichy
le vel d'hiv et toutes ces saloperies et
donc ça aussi
cette blessure l'a mitterrand l'avait il
ya une forme d'orgueil à ne pas l'avouer
guillaume georges-marc pour en finir sur
le bouquin est passé aux réactions le
lobby juif il l'entendait comment
mitterrand donc si vous disais ça c'est
klarsfeld
c'est clair c'est grave c'est que la
recette impulsion sa petite à sa petite
association très vaillante deux fils et
filles de déportés
je crois que ce mot finalement été
introduit par quelqu'un de son entourage
qui a fait de mauvaises actions n'ont
pas besoin puritains mais ça on fantasme
toujours quand un lobby juif en
l'occurrence c'est klarsfeld
et puis un certain nombre de gens
motivés mais finalement la question de
vichy comme la question de la guerre
d'algérie comme tout ça c'est le
problème de la france bien georges marc
y avait beaucoup de réactions à votre
livre dans le point la semaine dernière
il y avait les bonnes pages de votre
livre dans le point que cette semaine il
ya une lettre ouverte des amis de
françois mitterrand qui disent le
principal reproche qu'on peut faire à
françois mitterrand c'est d'avoir
accueilli des gens comme georges marc
benamou auprès de lui je veut rectifier
mais la place à la pétition charasse oui
assez la pétition charasse et pas les
amis sans cette erreur nombre de gens
oui oui c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas de pot
mitterrand l'avait déjà nathalie qui a
fait verbatim c'est vrai que voir je
suis confident un ami journaliste j'ai
jamais été conseiller spécial ministre
du budget médecin je suis un individu ni
puisqu'ils disent dans leur pétition
il faut quand même dire que disent les
gens sincères que personne n'a lu ce
livre c'est aussi sur le texte était
prêt avant que le livre soit imprimé
donc personne ne la lui monsieur value
dans le point la semaine dernière ils
ont peut-être lu des extraits m'enfin
ils ont lu les bonnes pages 3% le livre
et d'un livre complexe et d'un livre un
briquet d'un livre que j'ai mis des
années à écrire
ils ne l'ont pas lu mais monsieur
charasse dit partout d'ailleurs je ne
lirai pas ce livre mais c'est un torchon
vous pensez pas que le fait de faire un
livre où mitterrand repart du lobby juif
ça peut réveiller l'antisémitisme en
france
non parce que je crois que j'ai fait un
livre au contraire très nuancée pour
expliquer qu'il y avait il ya eu entre
1992 et 1995 une guerre de la mémoire
entre est un vrai débat de haut niveau
parfois parfois tortueux je pense que
j'ai voulu montrer une complexité
française la france ce n'est pas que le
mal
la france n'est pas que le bien que nous
disait de gaulle ça n'est pas qu'une
france héroïque c'est une france plus
complexes et enfants voir en couverture
du point lobby juif et qu'on sait que
c'est un mode mitterrand vous pensez pas
que ça peut s'est pas tu sais pas j'ai
veillé ou accélérer l'antisémitisme
latent squelette non non je pense que
l'entv 18 chose trop sérieuse pour qu'on
puisse traiter à tord et à travers les
gens d'antisémite et c'est pas le cas de
mitterrand il ya eu une brouille entre
mitterrand et les responsables de la
communauté juive
à un moment donné sur une question
précise sur ce avec certains
responsables il faut le dire faut pas
écrire une histoire faite de langue de
voir elle est très complexe
on râle humain
on va parler de tout ça
a été enlevé au chant jean galle
initial michal le vase y croit
quelle connerie tu es contente toi
maintenant javier l est
[Applaudissements]
javier est en larmes
alors donc effectivement vous noté dans
votre pipe le paren entre les événements
politiques et l'exécution de tapis vous
dit quand je lisais les sondages
je savais que nos ennuis judiciaires
s'amplifierait mais tapie avait une
faiblesse il se croyait invulnérable à
tout le monde que le tapis de l'époque
de la grande époque et pete est un homme
puissant
souvenez vous quand même dommage
invraisemblable et extraordinaire du
président la république avait un tapis
en pleine affaire mbia bien mais
monsieur mitterrand fait un hommage
appuyé à paris monsieur pierre mauroy
dit tout ce qui est bon pour moi mais
bon pour le ps à face et quand même des
choses fort ça fait mal mais ça vous
vous sentez alors vas voir toute
l'histoire donc avant lors m j'ai fait
des études supérieures de gestion de
finance de management et vous commencez
votre carrière dans des grands groupes
puis vous devenez consultant et puis
vous rentrez à l'om pourquoi est monté
par tapie facilement la vie j'aimerais
que chacun se souvient de ce qu'était
tapis dans les années 88
ouais c'était un radieux de la
communication il avait son émission
ambitions il avait fait son lit regagner
tout le monde le cite en exemple comme à
main sur l'entreprise
donc pour moi qui avait des ambitions de
faire aussi des affaires dans le futur
je venais près du pape de l'autre
musulman alors il y avait aussi d'algos
qu'il est très sympa très sympa à jouer
là vous travaillez dur vous rentrez à
l'om c'est c'est difficile mais vous
donner beaucoup de mal vous travaillez
sur les droits télé sur les loges vip et
les sponsors
le merchandising premier problème en
1990 donc il ya deux ans vous êtes là
vous êtes entendus pour une histoire de
transfert les transferts d'olmeta et
pardo qui venait de toulon et là où
passer une nuit en taule déjà on vous
demande à vous aimez vous savez pas quoi
oui c'est pas assez pas la taule c'est
la garde à vue ça arrive à tout le monde
que je vais choisir c'est tout ce qui
m'est arrivé peut arriver à tout le
monde rêve la garde à vue c'est les
policiers qui viennent ne viennent pas
pour nous ouais cela s'est très pervers
il
anne pour une affaire concernant toulon
le transfert de olmeta pardoe casoni et
ils ont la discussion bernès a signé
l'autorisation policiers les autorisant
à vérifier les comptes de l'om
s'étonnant a quand même et là
effectivement on nous pose beaucoup de
questions mais je réponds ce que j'ai
répondu moi j'ai pas changé et pourtant
je subis des pressions a dansé pendant
cette garde à vue et je tiens mes
positions
et depuis cette date là je pars varier
d'une seule subir gül de tout ce que
j'ai toujours dit depuis cette garde à
vue alors l'om marche à l'om connaît
beaucoup de succès malgré tout il ya des
problèmes avec vigouroux le maire de
marseille vous met des bâtons dans les
roues d'une façon assez systématique
chaque fois qu'il peut pas écouter
c'était flagrant
monsieur vigouroux avait le talent de
faire le contraire de ce qu'on proposait
comme ça marchait ils disent l inverse
ouais alors pierre affaires mba c'est à
dire on retrouve deux cent cinquante
mille fois en espèces dans le jardin de
la tante de glassman périgueux qui dit
voilà qui dit bernet smac corrompu il
m'a demandé de lever le pied
ouais l'écouté mais d'abord j'ai pas été
mis en examen dans cette affaire dont
nous je peux en parler qu'avec une
certaine distance ce que je sais c'est
qu'il n'y a aucun lien qui a été prouvé
entre les preuves matérielles présenté
notamment l'argent puisque ses preuves
matérielles
non aucun aucune empreinte n'ont qu'une
les billets ne correspondent pas des
billets qui viennent de marseille
la police a fait des investigations
énorme et croyez moi aussi d'aller
trouver quelque chose j'aurais été
forcément mis en examen moi c'est un set
ça reste une grande affaire extrêmement
douteuse troublante car on me fait pas
croire qu'un joueur de football qui sont
qui dépensent quand même pas mal
d'argent puis saint matin trois semaines
après ressortir une somme d'argent comme
ça et comme par hasard ça se passe le
jour où j'annonce la lancement de la
création d'une société extrêmement
importante qu'elle aime premier où
j'avais
ni plus de 300 chaînes entreprises
réseaux locaux ainsi que cinq
investisseurs de dimension
internationale je vais réunir 100
millions de francs qui avait pour objet
de rentrer dans le capital de l'om et
d'autre part d'aider les entreprises
régionales à se développer comme par
hasard comme bing forme en ce moment
leur argent dans ce jardin de la tante
de glace mappy régulateur eagle la paire
om premier qui était très prometteuse
effectivement ne se fait pas rire là la
police des coupes votre coffre fort au
chalumeau par ces abominables je trouve
un bureau on est saccagée pour vous ça
vous monte alors et berlin ses complices
non mais dites le moi je crois que le
pic de la sphère de mba est une affaire
totalement monté à partir du moment où
aucune des pièces
aucun des aucun des éléments qui
concerne l'om sont avérées faut bien
savoir que les joueurs de valenciennes
ne met pas en cause ni le web les tapis
vous met en cause bernès et puis et
quand même fait troublant bernès jusqu'à
roues jusqu'au procès a toujours soutenu
qu'il avait été piégé
je rappelle un truc que toulon est
oublié c'est lui qui dépose plainte
le premier contre les dirigeants de
valenciennes pour avoir lui-même été
comme corrompu donc faut pas oublier ça
c'est bien mais ce qu'il dépose plainte
en tout premier le 4 juillet c'est pas
valenciennes c'est pas la ligue c'est
bernet et jusqu'au procès il soutient sa
il écrivit un livre qui dit exactement
ça et le jour du procès comme par hasard
il fait exploser le livre qu'ils ont
complètement autre chose
il ya un manque de cohérence quand même
parce que tapie maintenant quand il
rencontre bernès dans un restaurant il
change de restaurants où il demande que
berné ce journal c'est quand même le
succès d avatar de l'oea
c'est quand même son inspiration du
clown à la sq dans la capitale en prison
je suis allé en prison sur les
déclarations peu mal quand même fait
alors 1994 bas effectivement il ya un
sondage dans vsd il ya même un
photomontage où bernard tapie était bien
présent la république et on dit ben
voila si elle est des élections
présidentielles entre chirac et tapis
tapie aurait 46 % et chirac 54 donc d'un
seul coup il devient sans doute
effectivement je veux dire pour un
certain nombre de barons de la gauche il
devient l'homme à abattre
hélas toutes les affaires lui tombe
dessus il ya au mba on vient d'en parler
il yal'affaire des comptes de l'om
et puis après il ya le phocéa testud etc
oui mais travaille pour voir ce qui se
passe je crois que c'est dans ce livre
quand je lis
j'avais peur même en l'écrivant lui sera
possible on prend pas tout ça dans la
tête n'y a pas que ça on veut nous faire
déposer le bilan
on nous met en examen c'est en 94 qu'on
ait mis en examen tout à l'heure vous
avez dit on est en garde à vue en 90
qu'est ce qui se passe entre 90 et 94
ria ouais non seulement il se passe rien
contre nous ça veut dire que finalement
ce qui était dit en 90 par la police
n'est pas si ya pas eu de suite sur la
fère ont fui la zone i pardo olmeta
wayne mais sur ce qu'on nous reproche
qu'on nous reproche plein de choses qui
vont ressortir
quatre ans après les affaires de
transformers 2 et terra tout ça ressort
après alors à l'époque donc tapis
devient incontournable son plan
politique effectivement à ce que les
européennes mais il est aussi par contre
là donc c'est le début de la la lie et
et vous notez d'ailleurs effectivement
des convergences des faits sur des
périodes très concentré exemple alors là
on voit la fin octobre 94 vous
rencontrez un investisseur pour l'om qui
prêt à financer le club est prêt à
investir dans le club et qui vous fait
nettement comprendre qu'en échange il
voudrait quand même quelques
informations sur leur tapis
wii passe à puce et puis c'est plus
pervers c'est à dire que c'est cet
investisseur n'était pas un investisseur
c'était un émissaire qui m'a demandé
clairement de prière tapis ouais c'est à
dire qu'on fait là chers amis je suis le
seul qui ait jamais trahi et c'est
justement j'y vais je n'ai pas trahi
alors
cet ami ça me dit quoi il me dit que
c'est la fille qui nous a laissé il n'y
aura pas de problème pour vous en
matière pénale si vous me dites des
choses importantes aussi bon et on est
en pleine période d'avant que devant
élection et cette fois c'est amusant
parce qu'on est en gros six mois que
cinq mois avant les élections
bernès sans avocat à ce moment là tiens
c'est curieux mois on propose de
travailler quinze jours après mais on en
ce contrôle judiciaire avec interdiction
de travail au lendemain il se passe
beaucoup de choses a été infiniment la
vraie fincken réclame dans toute cette
affaire monsieur je vous ai monté une
société avec kara georgis donc l'agent
de l'om bon une société qui n'a jamais
travaillé une société en qui est restée
en sommeil mais c'est sûr que le juge
philippon ça vous a pas rendu crédible à
ses yeux mai juin juillet tendue à ce
moment une perche aux normes d'abord
c'est moi qui lui dit au juge c'est pas
lui qui le trouve
ouais et moi spontanément parce que je
pensais pas qu'il y avait vraiment péril
en la demeure mais lui il pensait que
cette société xavier montet avec le
carat georgis est en fait une planque
pour une caisse noire de l'om bien sûr
ils me disent pas possible tout le monde
ce passage orange en tout le monde soit
au courant parce qu'on avait des
processeurs très contrôlés on avait du
commissaire aux comptes des double
signature
je dis non c'est un truc personnel
j'assume je vais pas raconter comme tout
c'est à pisser mois la russie fait ça et
pourquoi vous parce que j'avais envie de
faire du commerce comme j'explique dans
le livre mon but c'était après de faire
autre chose que l'om ça après un stress
énorme bond puis je sois notre président
bernard tapie bien sûr je laime c'est un
homme merveilleux
mais je crois que là malgré cela les met
et las palmas il a fait un disque en
sort avec une
donc ouais c'est clair j'ai envie de
faire autre chose mais le juge rue la
sueur ils avaient le choix le juge il me
dit soit c'est pour vous à titre privé
puis je vous poursuit pour abus soit
c'est pour l'osm caisses noires
rutilantes et les 15 et ses pensées dans
tous les cas j'étais eu lim tenait bien
ça c'est que les résistants tous les cas
j'étais justement on va parler des juges
philippe on chez vous vous étiez la
lumière est ici aussi
à la roche est-ce que vous jurer
aujourd'hui que le juge philippe on vous
a promis un assouplissement de votre
sort si vous balancier bernard tapie
absolument j'ai subi des pressions de
toutes natures et puis toute la
procédure qui a suivi juste plus le
philippon a largement démontré que
c'était pas le mettre une pression pour
me faire avouer quelque chose donc il y
avait un chantage
manifestement c'est un chantage aux
femmes extrêmement violent mais c'est un
chantage en régime
[Applaudissements]
effectivement
alain laroche là on vous met en prison
d'abord on vous met à l'évêché pendant
dix heures sans boire et sans manger
dans vous découvrez effectivement la
dure vie des prisonniers cdu part très
importante de votre livre c'est très
touchant la façon dont vous en parler
avant vous mais aux baumettes sans
prévenir votre famille bah c'est l'enfer
le pire moment ça a était quoi d'abord
d'abord on comprend rien du tout parce
que c'est oui j'avais pris un coup de
poing à la figure
j'étais complètement ko ce n'est
heureusement que j'ai vu des ressources
morales au delà de normal parce que
sinon on peut mourir il ya des gens dans
la suicide pour moi que ça donc c'est
très dur en permanence
et puis je ne savais pas ce qui allait
se passer quand vous êtes en prison pour
trois mois six mois plus dense et vous
organiser n'oubliez pas également que
j'étais incarcéré contre l'avis du
procureur c'est quand même dingue
en 1995 un simple juge d'instruction un
homme peut vous mettre en prison
sur sa seule décision contre l'avis du
procureur je voudrais insister là dessus
en plus je suis peut-être seul français
rentre en prison pour avoir avoir payé
pour entrer en prison j'ai payé ma
caution la veille mesures entreprises
ont passé des choses incroyables quand
on nous raconte alors c'était dur tous
les jours
bien sûr mais c'était sous surtout dur
quand je devais voir ma femme ou parloir
parce que là c'est l'humiliation torride
apprécions aussi ils ont menacé votre
femme de la mettre en examen tous mais
tous mes amis tous mes proches ont été
entendus avec des pressions ma femme est
effectivement a subi elle même
des fortes pressions allant très très
loin il est évident que dans le livre
j'en parle mais quelque part j'ai encore
de l'humilité et la pudeur parler parce
que quand je vais envoyer et puis que je
faisais mais ce qu'on lui faisait dehors
c'était terrible alors autre pression
vous êtes confrontés à bernay sur les
matches achetés vous vous dites non à ma
connaissance qui appelle de deux matches
achetés
alors est ce que il y en a pas eu des
matches achetés ou est-ce que vous ne
saviez pas qu'il y en a eu
moi je parle de ce que je sais c'est à
dire que tapie ne m'a jamais dit la
roche
il faut organiser de telles choses
telles choses près donc les rumeurs j'en
ai entendu des centaines
je n'ai jamais eu d'instruction jamais
eu un ordre pour fellak en sorte
voilà alors philippon le juge philippe
pendant vous faire craquer vous craquez
pas justement est-ce que vous craquez
pas parce que vous n'avez rien à dire ou
parce que vous êtes très fort
mentalement
nous avons la foulée 2 il faut d'abord
être très fort mentalement parce qu'on
peut dire n'importe quoi
ouais vous savez il ya des gens qui
disent n'importe quoi qui avoue ne fait
ce qui était arrivé at il souhaité tous
les actes que j'ai accompli j'ai
accompli en conscience et usa compris en
conscience parce que je pensais que
c'était nécessaire pour le club c'était
dans l'intérêt de l'entreprise et que
j'avais pris toutes les précautions de
vérification auprès des avocats des
conseils du ministre du budget lui la
justice la ligue et parce que c'est des
pratiques connues dans le football c'est
tout donc je n'avais pas le sentiment de
faire des choses va abominable savez
quand on est quand on relit l'arrêt de
la cour d'appel
on se dit mais c'est pas possible qu'on
vous ait fait ça avant justement un jour
avoir un jour de novembre
vous vous retrouvez seul en tenue d'été
devant la porte des baumettes et c'est
un gardien qui vous raccompagne à
marseille
votre femme n'avait pas été prévenue
dans l'administration pénitentiaire de
votre retour
alors après le procès vous prenez de la
prison avec sursis dont vous découvrirez
cependant que j'ai fait 5 mois et
quelques mois une semaine de prison
ferme pour rien pour rien il fait 5 mois
une semaine nous faisons absolument pour
rien mais attendez moi j'ai une question
simple à la si vous avez été condamnée
même à de la prison avec sursis oui et à
200 mille francs d'amendé
oui il ya bien quand même quelque part
une culpabilité je lui même je ne
conteste pas j'espère les votre
culpabilité alors je l'expliquais c'est
quand même important de savoir qu'on a
été condamné les barreaux pourquoi
est-ce qu'on était comme elle l'est pour
trois raisons 1 ont fait des prêts aux
joueurs deuxième choix au joueur
deuxièmement les contrats d'image
les joueurs m'ont des gens des images
comme une vedette de cinéma
et le troisième fois c'est les affaires
sérieuses football s'il appelait à plus
petite part du dossier ont payé des
commissions et les a pressés de football
pourquoi pour faciliter les transferts
pour avoir des renseignements
confidentiels sur des clubs c'est ce que
tous les clubs font entendre
voilà les trois raisons c'est pas les
choses qui sont graves
c'est des choses qui sont allés
discutable bien donc vous avait été pris
dans les rouages d'une opération de
déstabilisation politique j'ai été pris
parce que j'ai pris une position loyal
je suis quelqu'un qui a cette vertu est
une vertu c'est un défaut parfois
peut-être mais en tout cas c'est la
mienne
alala charbon à dire vers la piste ce
soir vous regardez votre caméra vous lui
dites quoi moi je dis bonjour parce que
je n'ai pas revu depuis pas mal de temps
et bon courage parce que la sphère va
être difficile
j'espère que l'on va réussir et gt2
quelques conseils à lui donner et un
mauvais fonctionnement financier et
e-business un mot à bernès chacun fait
sa vie on est maître de son destin
j'ai choisi mais ma voix ce que je sais
c'est que quand je me regarde je suis en
harmonie avec moi-même et je peux parler
en face avec tout le monde je regarde
dans les yeux et je suis fier par
rapport à mme simplement mes gosses mais
aussi par rapport aux marseillais et aux
supporters marseillais d'avoir fait ce
que j'ai fait pour un grand club que
j'aime encore
en labo
le jingle on ne bouge pas pendant les
tinner
bien alors pendant le procès festina
devait assumer la responsabilité
vous avez reconnu le dopage mais voilà
le problème c'est que rien n'a changé et
cette fois vous c'est sûr les dirigeants
et les organisateurs que vous mettez la
pression vous les mettez en cause
vous dites par exemple en parlant du
patron de l'union cycliste
internationale qui s'appelle verbruggen
vous dites quand verbruggen dit qu'à des
problèmes dans le tour d'italie le giro
il dit c'est un incident de plus il
oublie de dire qu'il conduit le bus
depuis des années au finalement
effectivement ce n'est beaucoup pris il
ya trois ans aux coureurs
vous vous dites que oui les coureurs ce
ne sont que des victimes finalement et
que si on est courageux
c'est aux dirigeants du cyclisme
français international qui rassemble
pendant effectivement je dis ici nous
sommes tous responsables de nos actes et
les coureurs les premiers au premier
degré au second degré y sont victimes
d'un système victime d'une faillite
totale de ce qui avait le mandat de la
lutte antidopage et qui en minimisant le
problème depuis des décennies n'ont fait
que conforter les cyclistes dont la
continuité de pratiquer l'ici et c'est
bien là failles de tout un système
aujourd'hui qui révélait alors question
dopage
vous dites que le rsr 13 à remplacer le
p o
donc finalement bon voilà il ya plus de
theo ben faiza un truc nouveau qui est
encore plus indétectable de toute façon
vous dites que dans le dans le milieu du
cyclisme dopage c'est presque une gloire
dire que des anciens se raconte comme ça
à la veillée des histoires de dopage a
tu te souviens quand on est pris un pot
belge ans était à c'était bien marrer
tous donc ça fait partie c'est culturel
la dope enfin le dopage chez les
cyclistes est quelque chose de tout à
fait normal quoi
alors là ont tous quelque chose de
culturel effectivement et puis d'un peu
dramatique c'est de banaliser ces choses
là le soir à la veillée en un ancien ne
fait que effectivement enlever toute
forme de
de prise de conscience et de culpabilité
éventuelle
des cyclistes c'est à dire comment
voudrait-on que des fils spirituels
prennent conscience de leur erreur si
les pères se glorifie de leurs aînés
quoi voilà c'était comme lequel deux
roues chez les mineures donc pas en quoi
c'est à dire tout mon bois son petit
mitron là c'est pareil on se fait seul
petit shoot de p o
ça fait partie du ça fait partie du truc
quoi lui c'est juste je trouve j'étais
mineure armements et c'est vrai qu'il ya
une espèce de façon d'obliger les jeunes
à accepter l'inacceptable par des rites
de passage comme ça voilà donc vous
parler de la dot mais ce qui est le plus
étonnant dans votre bouquin et ont bon
l'accent a beaucoup été mis là dessus
ces derniers jours mais c'est vrai que
c'est très étonnant parce que nous
pauvres mortels on connaissait
l'histoire du dopage dans le cyclisme on
sait pas quelle est la corruption
moi je savais pas du tout ça c'est un
truc que j'ai appris en lisant votre
livre par exemple virenque a acheté 100
mille francs
sa victoire sur l'allemand jan ullrich à
courchevel dans le tour de france 97
c'est un truc qu'on savait pas que vous
avez révélé que non seulement il au fond
tous il s'achète les uns les autres
partis en faute
comment ça s'est passé bien donc ils
sont tous les deux fait raconter nous
racontez nous la le moment où il lui
fait comme ça quoi
je voudrais préciser avant que
contrairement à ce qui a été présenté il
ya quelques jours on a voulu enfin une
certaine presse a voulu faire une
affaire om mais a bis repetita j'aurai à
rétablir un peu les choses c'est à dire
qu'il n'ya pas eu de match acheté au
départ il ya eu une belle bagarre ce
jour là ouais on a mis l'équipe dans
l'équipe festina mis l'équipe telekom à
genoux toute la journée et les deux
champions se sont livrés une belle
bataille mais il est vrai et vous vous
doutez bien qu'il ait écrit s'exhaler
ebr il ya eu entente entre les deux
coureurs dans les derniers kilomètres et
on voit ce geste qui a nos éléments
c'est ça et même s'il ya d'autres mecs
de l'équipe qu'ils empruntent aurait pu
attendre qu'il ait pas de caméra pour
faire ça parce que là franchement tout
le monde tu as vu donc alors ça fait
partie un peu des us et coutumes je dis
pas que ça se produit à chaque fois mais
effectivement là c'est le même phénomène
j'ai eu à le dire jean marie leblanc le
premier en 1971 dans les 4 jours de
dunkerque a vendu ses services pour
l'équivalent d'un tiers de son mois de
salaire à l'équipe de roger de vlaeminck
donc une équipe
effectivement dans ses mémoires on sur
l'autobiographie le patron du tour de
france actuelle leblanc dit que lui
effectivement il a il a roulé pour de
vlaeminck pour 2011 c'est à dire non
mais c'est un cadeau des exemples on va
pas citer parce qu'elle a beaucoup mais
ça veut dire que la corruption c'est à
dire c'est courant donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on savait pas nous paraît
effectivement le pire c'est qu'il dit en
99 c'est qu'il ait pas choquer voilà
encore une fois la fille spirituelle que
peuvent-ils penser il faut comprendre
aussi que pour les gens du milieu
le mot correct corruption ne convient
pas tellement c'est à dire pour les
personnes dans la rue effectivement
c'est une corruption
là ça s'appelle dédommagement pour
victoire manquer quoi lasser des us et
coutumes reproduit de décennie en
décennie qui fait qu'il ya une espèce de
banalisation et qui déculpabilise
individuel comment ça se passe sous nos
roues celle ci lui fait ça l'ofc fait
d'accord donc je vais laisser gagner tu
vas me filer du pognon mais ils n'ont
pas le temps étant sur des vélos de
discuter le montant non ça c'est pendant
la course dans la course il lui fait
quoi mais ça comme ça donc l'hôte dit du
doigt quelque chose et le lendemain
c'est vous qui allez sur un parquet je
rencontre quelqu'un
membre proche de jan ullrich et qui me
donne le montant de la somme et vous 10
700 milles et vous vous dites je vais
quand même demander avis rentes mais
c'est vrai que cent mille pour une
victoire comme ça c'est pas si cher que
ça par rapport à l'enjeu et à
l'événement effectivement j'ai pas été
choqué à ce moment-là douala de la somme
de 100 mais l'autre ça s'est disputée
entre coureurs
j'apprends l'information après
effectivement on donne une somme si elle
paraît raisonnable par rapport à l'enjeu
elle et elle est acceptée et les deux
coureurs s'arrange après est ce qu'ils
disent et rsa versé des sommes qui sont
pratiquement les bords du gave course
qui est valide normalement sans trucage
il faut plus jamais dit ça il y a plus
de courses à la régulière qu'il y à deux
courses acheter
d'ailleurs les us et coutumes aurait
voulu que ce jour là le maillot jaune en
seigneur laisse la victoire d'étape à
son veillant à son vaillant dauphin
rupture ans richard ça c'est des us et
coutumes et c'est pour ça que l'on dit
d'ailleurs si un seigneur il a fait
preuve il a été brillant ni envers
richard et pourquoi lui ce jour là at il
voulu
monnayer je n'en sais rien les jeunes 17
ans et un allemand de l'ex rda peut-être
d'une génération où il était encore
imprégné de toutes cultures et il a
dérapé déjà que je voulais dire quelque
chose je voulais seulement dit à moi que
j'aime beaucoup le sport cycliste et il
peut se passer certainement plein de
choses que monsieur roussel connaît
mieux probablement qui compte
je mets que je m'étonne simple je
m'étonne un petit peu je m'étonne un
petit peu que monsieur roussel qui était
le patron de viron way dans cette
fameuse étape a trouvé ça formidable
le jour de l'arrivée des tours de france
et la poya trouvé sa sensationnelle et
la partager la victoire de virenque je
suis un peu surpris que quelques années
après ce sens des états d'âme sinon il a
été donné hussein a été jugée tout ça
que j'ai été condamné vous avez vous
appris de la prison avec sursis vous a
été condamné à une amende
et puis après ils auraient pu revenir
comme bernard tapie n'aurait pu revenir
dans le système du chiffre simplement ce
qu'il est en train de faire roussel ce
qui brûle c'est des sceaux c'est à dire
qu'il est en train de faire une
politique de terre brûlée parce que bien
évidemment après ce qu'il dit là il
restera dans l'immobilier en bretagne
retournera jamais en plaçant tel qu'il
était terriblement le règlement de
comptes et choc le livre qui sort juste
avant le tour de france tout ça c'est
lent c'est rien ça mais ça me laisse ça
me laisse un goût doute tous les détails
complets dans tous les cas de figure
j'ai maintenant mais j'aime pas trop ça
voilà éteignez la lumière
du tout bruno roussel est ce qu'il ne
s'agit pas tout simplement d'un
règlement de comptes
non c'est un retour aux sources pour moi
j'étais un éducateur et aujourd'hui je
suis beaucoup mieux dans ma peau que je
ne l'étais et j'assume parfaitement ce
que j'ai écrit et d'ailleurs je suis
prêt à venir
il argumenté devant qui que ce soit or
louis hayes dé quoi comme ça c'est très
inattendu on peut avoir la question qui
tue notre attention vous quand vous
serez président de la république
question qui tue sept élèves attention
je voudrais juste rajouter changer la
loi du silence est la pire et en
écrivant ce livre effectivement j'ai
clair sur des moeurs et des pratiques et
la seule question qui à mon avis mérite
d'aider battue c'est quel sport
voulons-nous pour demain en fait c'est
celle là
et est ce que pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants
est ce qu'on souhaite que les coureurs
cyclistes jacques y aura peut-être un
petit fils ou un arrière petit fils qui
va faire du vélo est ce qu il veut que
son petit fils ou son arrière petit fils
ils vivent ce que vivent aujourd'hui les
cyclistes alors on peut dire
effectivement vous nous roussel et
créera il a plein de défauts les bruno
roussel aujourd'hui il dit qu'il a dit
la vérité et pour moi c'est un retour
aux sources et j'ai voulu éclairer
quelque chose beaucoup moins
effectivement que richard le lait c'est
pas tellement richard j'ai voulu
attaquer dans ce livre c'est la faillite
des institutions
oui alors suite à votre bouquin virenque
richard virenque eux lui ni ils disent
jamais acheté cette victoire ulrich nies
aussi mais effectivement willy woeth ex
soigneur de virenque donc de l'équipe
festina dit le soir du massage donc il
parle avec diront qu il lui dit mais tu
aurais pas acheter le la victoire n'a
pas payé quand même et à ce moment-là
virenque dit willy veux tu lui réponds
si donc ça faire un témoin alors on
apprend même dans votre bouquin que jean
claude killy et pourtant pour nous enfin
lui a si on doit non merci
jean claude killy il sort pas indemne
des révélations de bruno roussel le 11
juillet 98 quand il veut d'eux vient
d'être arrêté avec le coffre plein de
seringue et de p o
il reçoit bruno roussel en compagnie de
jean marie leblanc qui est le patron du
tour de france et qu'il y dit à russell
merdes bruno pourquoi tu nous a pas
prévenus avant ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que si vous les aviez
prévenu avant il aurait pu arranger le
coup je me suis posé la question
je me suis sans doute trompé
et donc
je pense que il était lui aussi pressé
de questions par les journalistes il
devait il devait avoir à répondre de
cette voiture de la société du tour qui
mais c'est vrai qu'après cet entretien
je me suis posé la question
le doute s'est installé dans mon esprit
mais bon il s'est sûrement trompé savoir
tous les droits du livre ont une
association anti dopage ou un truc comme
ça c'est pour vous alors j'ai reçu un à
valoir
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle une avance
et je les ai je les ai prises et son et
sont pour moi j'ai pas pris de décision
par rapport à effectivement c'est
vraiment pour dénoncer faudrait que ça
serve à quelque chose
[Musique]